This is Jocko podcast number one 27 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
You Owe Jima is to me,
hallowed blessing.
Spiritual,
sacred,
pure ground.
If the spirits of the dead could speak,
what would they be saying to me?
Count off Marines and sailors.
You have the vanquish dead when you're number reaches 7,000 we will know that
you are present and accounted for in this.
Your eternal duty station
serve well.
Your ranks are growing each passing day as some of us,
your mates and war are coming to join you.
Those endless hours of terrifying nights,
the carnage,
devastation and pain turned hope into despair.
The remnants of formally dynamic human bodies that carried hearts filled with
dreams of peace,
home and loved ones.
After the rush of battle,
my eyes became heavy with tears.
My body trembled with rage.
As I looked upon the broken bodies,
the searing invasion of human flesh,
aftermath of war,
an elemental suffocating fear through and through my very soul.
The intensely surging immediacy of the action was aggravated.
No place to hide.
There was not only an incompatibilities between the marines and the defending
jobs,
but the very nature of this morbid little island.
Okay.
The sounds of battle,
which we're intensified by the human voice with all its emotions are absent
today.
The moral revulsion that took place here so many years ago has been forgotten
except by those who fought here and survived
and those who lost lost loved ones here.
Yeah,
and that is an excerpt from a book called
Hell yes.
I do it again,
written by a man
actually written by a marine named t Fred Harvey,
who fought in war two in the Pacific
feet theater,
including in the battle of Iwo Jima where he was severely wounded for a second
time,
but he survived the war and his lived an amazing life and it is an incredible
honor to have this hero here with us to share some of the lessons that he
learned.
Mr. Harvey,
welcome to the show.
I'm glad to be here.
I've heard a lot about this show and I'm really pleased that you've invited me
to come here and to speak to the,
yeah.
Well maybe you can just keep coming back because we'll just sit and listen to
you.
We got no problem with that,
sir.
Um,
so I guess we always try and go back to the beginning a little bit and learn a
little bit about you and,
and I know you're,
you're growing up and your book has a bunch of incredible anecdotal stories
about what it was like growing up in Texas during the depression.
So,
you know,
I was talking to you earlier and I said,
people don't know what the depression was really like.
And uh,
you described it in one word.
You said hungry.
So that's a real thing,
huh?
During the depression?
Yeah,
that was a real thing.
I vividly remember all the good times while leading and the hungry times when I
was really hungry.
I joined the Marine Corps.
That's the first time I had adequate food.
Satisfied that hunger within.
So,
and you,
you,
you grew up with a single mom for the most part.
So you,
I know your dad was doing good in construction,
but then the depression hit.
Yeah,
the depression hit and it really hit the Harvey family at one time.
The Harvard family consisted of 11 people,
nine girls,
two boys,
uh,
father and mother.
And My mother was the center of my universe when I went into the Marine Corps
and the last night that are spending,
no Dasha before I got to bootcamp.
Okay.
The train stopped in my hometown of Odessa.
And they had the band high school band and a lot of people from town are there
to greet us.
That conductor say,
we're going to stop for 20 minutes because people are voted as a,
to see off every three of us going into the Marine Corps at that time when we
got er,
there were girls there that were throwing kisses on me that never dreamed to be
unable to even touch him.
And I was about ready to quit the marine corps and stay there.
Well,
during all,
there's some,
somebody grabbed my ear and jerked me around behind the depo and it was my mom,
Jesse Lee.
She,
my mom was a Comanche Indian and she was a warrior.
She pulled me around in the dark or the,
uh,
night behind the,
outside of the crowd so nobody could hear what she had to say.
And she called me Sunday because I was so bright.
She put these,
this hand up in front of me like this or there so I can see it.
She said,
Sonny,
you listen and you listen.
Good.
Yes ma'am.
She said,
number one,
when this war is over,
you come home to us
ma'am
and don't you come home,
no drunkard
and you don't come home,
no coward.
You know what that fourth one was
and you don't come home with no tattoos
and I sure don't have any tattoos.
And that was when she sent me off to San Diego.
And uh,
I'll tell you a little bit later in this session,
she came out to see me and you don't see the reason why she came out to see me.
So,
uh,
you actually at one point,
um,
and I thought that was a real interesting thing cause it seemed like you got a
lot of weight on your shoulders as a young,
as a youngster.
And I'm gonna go to the book here for a minute.
I greeted my mom cheerfully.
She avoided my eyes and this is just you coming home from school,
I had greeted my mom cheerfully,
his usual.
She avoided my eyes and wiped her own with her apron.
I noted with concern a puffy redness about them.
She got up and went to the oven and brought out a baked potato in a big bowl of
pinto beans thanking her.
I dug in in silence.
She entered that same bedroom.
My thoughts centered wholly on the food.
Without preamble,
I heard a loud beseechingly desperate cry come through the closed door.
No Jesse,
not that.
And that was your dad with a gasp.
I spewed a mouthful of food,
knocked over the small table and went through the door without benefit of the
knob in the dimly lit bedroom.
I viewed a scene of heart choking horror,
a picture forever etched in my memory.
My father desperately grappled for the pistol.
My mother tried to bring down on herself or him
without wavering or hesitation.
I lunged at her with all the force I could muster.
I caught her with a fist to the side of her head.
She sagged at the knees,
drop the pistol and fell forward.
A nurse.
She laid down on the floor.
I was horrified by what I had done.
My father's staggered back and slumped whimpering into a corner.
I headed to the bathroom and came out with a bath towel sopping wet with cold
water.
I applied it to her suffering face until she came around on steadily.
I helped her to her feet and then see it her on the side of the bed.
All the while dad remained in the corner to shaking,
to get up or offer any assistance to shaking,
to get up or offer any assistance sobbing.
I cried.
Why mother?
Why?
With a clear,
steady voice.
She said,
your daddy does not love us anymore.
He has another woman.
That's a lot of a lot for a young kid to deal with.
Yeah.
It was the saddest moment my whole life.
I'll never forget that.
And uh,
my mom was a great mom.
She held the family together after he left us.
He plowed the,
for the divorce and I want to do that,
the judge's chamber with my mother
and the judge calls me and my father to come to him and my mom was too weak to
get up to get,
go to the judge.
The judge said,
Mr. Harvey,
um,
granted your divorce,
the six remaining children and their family will remain with their mother and
you would pay in the sum of $42 for child care a month
for six children and her sale.
And that was her last a my dad ever spent on us.
And uh,
we just divorced him completely from our minds and so forth.
I had nothing to do with him after that.
And uh,
that we're to society this moment of my whole life when,
okay.
That happened.
And,
um,
it was interesting too.
You mentioned later in the book that you could have gotten,
because now you were like the sole supporter of the family.
You could have actually gotten a deferment from going to the war.
Yes.
Uh Huh.
And,
and your mom,
okay.
Like didn't give it to you or she knew that you wanted to go in the Marine
Corps?
Yeah.
Well if for a while she held off
sign the papers for me to go.
She always just sophomore high school
and I was failing all my subjects because I was trying to hold down two jobs to
help my mom and my sisters.
And uh,
it was,
it was hard times.
It was
really bad for her soul,
but my mom hill,
the rest of us together and,
and I lived through it.
And then so your mom knew that you wanted to join the Marine Corps?
Yeah.
And uh,
she fought down it.
And,
uh,
one day my cousin came home and I went to the recruiting office room with him
and he signed up because he was old enough to sign and I took the papers home to
my mom.
She was at the clothes line hanging up clothes to be dried,
you know,
and up put that paper in front of her.
I said,
this is for you to sign on when she's decided now cause I'm going into the
Marine Corps.
She laid that wet towel on the basket,
walked down here to the end of the line.
I'd built her a land for drying clothes and there were some excess wire,
six strand wire.
She took that thing and twisted into a long whip like thing came back to me,
took my left hand,
her left hand and whack me cross her rear and I made a complete circle around it
and I stopped and glared at her and I could see that she was shedding tears the
first years have ever had ever seen her said that broke my heart.
And
I stood there for awhile and she turned and walked and went into the house.
And then,
uh,
I cried,
I cried hard.
And so about a week later,
I came home from school and she handed me a paper that she had signed for me to
go into the Marine Corps.
And,
uh,
so that was the birth of my Marine Corps.
How old were you?
I was 17.
I was 17 and,
and uh,
I couldn't pass English and so I quit school and join the Marine Corps,
but they more,
where were you when,
where were you when Pearl Harbor happened?
So that was what,
a year prior?
No,
I was in school,
but it was a Sunday day and Jake roads,
my buddy had a little coop,
right.
Die and we had dates and we called her big birthers.
The little coop was too small for all of us to sit abreast of each other.
So I sit on her lap.
I just weighed 118 pounds and she probably outweighed me by a five or six
pounds.
And,
uh,
we heard that Pearl Harbor had been attacked and that
it was a day that I learned that I was going to be
involved in a war because age,
you know.
And so,
uh,
how would you heard about the marine corps as opposed to the army or the navy?
Well,
I wanted to be a paratrooper and then I thought I'd go into the army and be a
paratrooper.
Didn't have found out that the marines had paratroopers.
So I joined the Marine Corps and did and now found me a home.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you,
you leave on that train.
Your mom tells you,
you know,
don't be a coward,
don't get any tattoos and don't be a drunkard and come home to us.
Beezer good basic fundamental rules for a lot of people I think to follow.
And you had off on that train to boot camp,
which is right here in San Diego,
California.
Yes.
So I got through boot camp.
Okay.
Uh,
but a big problem when they land us up,
we fitted out with shoes and clothing and everything.
When it came to the shoes,
they management and they said,
son,
you can't join the Marine Corps because your feet are too small.
And I thought,
well gosh,
he not going to send me home is,
you know,
I wore off size five and a half.
And he said,
we just don't make shoes that small.
And so I had an old pair of shoes that had worn out,
should've been thrown away and I play a lot of poker.
I knew how to play poker before I knew my abcs.
Well anyway,
I carry cards around all the time.
So when I went to Marine Corps,
I had to use the whole deck,
putting about three into my shoes that had holes in them,
my civilian shoes that had holes in them.
And uh,
they finally,
one night,
uh,
I'd always take the top bunk in wherever I went,
what Barack says in,
you know,
so I put my shoes on the deck under the bond and the next morning I woke up and
there was the,
it's kind of muddy,
taken a car tire and cut out,
sold for me.
It was about that thick,
you know,
so had a pair of shoes that I could march in and anyway,
and then,
uh,
when,
I had to cut down my Dung dungarees cut down,
you know,
cause it was too big and so forth.
And I had a lot of trouble because I was so small.
And now the,
at one time I was small enough that Ralph Hall,
my captain or my platoon leader,
he was a first lieutenant at that time and not for Ferris,
picked me as
a runner.
And so one night we were sitting around the campfire and,
uh,
and I said,
why did y'all put,
picked me as uh,
as you,
as a runner?
And they said,
well,
you were so small,
so you made a small target and he was true fast afoot that you can run out,
run any jap in the row in the world.
So that was redone.
That was made account,
uh,
company runner.
So you were saying that your mom,
if it's in the book too,
it's a great story about your mom bringing you something to boot camp visiting.
He's been bringing you something to boot camp?
Oh yeah.
Well it wasn't exactly the boot camp is when I came back from overseas and the
found out that the going to be in,
uh,
a a demolition man in assault squad and assault squad was composed of five men.
We specials and,
uh,
I was going to be a,
a a demolition man as opposed to carry so many pounds of demolition and went
back and,
and owned a front.
I would care my regular pack,
you know,
and so forth.
And so I couldn't handle a raffle.
So out first I said,
well,
we've tried to get you a pistol because it couldn't handle the rifle,
uh,
with all that weight and so forth.
And uh,
he said,
we going to get you a pistol.
I've waited around a week for a pistol and finally came out.
I said,
the Marine Corps doesn't have any pistols,
any,
any left.
And so I was desperate.
So I called my mom.
I said,
mom,
find me a pistol.
I'd like to have a Colt 1911 colt.
And my mom went out
and,
uh,
looked all over town.
Well,
I looked all over San here for a pistol myself and it just wasn't one to be had,
you know.
And so I called my mom and told her what I needed and she,
uh,
I centers the money.
I sent her $75 that had one at a poker game.
I sent that to her and she went around all over town looking for a pistol,
couldn't find one until she came to a trailer house down close to the railroad
tracks with a guy that had a gun shop there.
So she went to the house trailer and knocked on the door and,
and Mr. Armstrong came out and said,
what do you need ma'am?
She says,
I need a pistol.
What kind of pistol do you need?
She said,
she took out the piece of paper that I'd written it on a Colt 45,
1911.
And he said,
I just happened to have one of those.
And,
uh,
she said,
how much he it and he said,
a $200.
And she said,
Oh,
I can't afford that.
He said,
well,
that's all the god.
Why do you need such a big pistol?
She said,
well,
my son is in the marine corps and he needs a pistol.
And so he said,
well this is the only one I have $200
and,
and so she backed it out of the door and went down to Rome.
Mr. Armstrong came down and tapped her.
So she said,
he said,
he say his son was in the Marine Corps and,
and needs a pistols.
Surely they can give him a pistol,
learn.
She said no,
they don't have any and she had come on back,
we'll work up a deal.
So she walked out that pistol cleaned of cosmoline and he had his $75 and she
needed to get to there as soon as she could,
you know.
So she went down to the bus station,
got on a bus with a paper grocery bag in it with extra clothes,
you know,
and got on the bus and 36 hours later she got the San Diego now seat criss
crossed because in those days,
you know,
military guys had a priority and she'd be in one place.
He would bump her off,
let her guy come in and take a place and she criss cross.
You may go in Arizona,
uh,
for 36 hours or where are we at loading up to go overseas and a cobber darts.
And I were up on the truck with a bunch of sea bags and,
uh,
Fisher,
my,
uh,
sergeant at that time,
was sitting in the cab with the driver and everything.
So we went to the gate over here at Camp Pendleton and,
uh,
Kate Gorge said,
is there any marine up?
Our named Harvey,
Fred Harvey and Carver woke me up.
I was asleep.
What we have said,
hey,
they had called him for your named.
So it flipped over and I saw them,
a mom look up at me and I slid low thing real fast.
I came off a real fat.
Well,
uh,
after a while,
Fisher said,
uh,
we gotta we got to go,
I want to let your mom sit in a seat and I'll get up.
Are we deal?
And so we drove down town and was looking for a place for her to stay.
We couldn't find a place anywhere.
I mean,
we tried ever hold tailed and so forth.
So finally,
I,
uh,
this is around 12 o'clock at night.
And so,
uh,
I went to a policeman and I said,
sir,
can you tell me where we might find a place for my mom to stay a hotel or motel
or something,
you know?
And he said,
well,
I just don't know of any place and so forth.
I'll tell you what,
I'll call my wife.
If he mother was stay at with her,
I'll call her and we'll go out.
And so the,
I've said yes,
bring her van around.
So,
uh,
he called off office and the police car came out and drove into the house and
his wife well welcomed us with open arms,
you know,
and she stayed there three different nights.
And,
uh,
and then I was able to,
Fisher would let me off,
uh,
quite a bit.
At the time,
there were three days she was here and then she finally had to put her on the
bus.
And he wrote her a note making a priority.
She wouldn't be bumped and everything when she got home.
Well that was a story of how I got my pistol.
And it was shortly there after that you went on,
you had an overseas?
Yes.
And that was on,
uh,
on,
a formal former cattle ship.
Is that right?
That was the first time I went overseas.
Okay.
So you came back in between,
in between,
so that you got the pistol after your first time going overseas?
Yeah,
it was the second time I went overseas.
Okay.
The first time I went over it was on the bloom fund team.
If you want to hear about the bloom Fontane well,
I read about it and it's a pretty nasty story in many ways.
That was a nasty shit,
but I thought that was the way it was.
You know,
I hadn't seen the ocean.
Dylan had gotten in the Marine Corps and so,
uh,
they,
they put us on,
on the bloom Fontane and it was then a cattle ship at Dutch,
at a Dutch cat plan.
And he was,
uh,
he shipped a,
I mean,
he transferred cattle from Australia over to,
uh,
through the Dutch,
a holdings in them South Pacific.
Well,
when the war broke out,
he had just dumped out a load of cattle.
And when he found out that it was at war,
well he hitted for San Francisco,
you know,
you got to San Francisco,
he offered it to the navy and the navy took it,
made it into a troop ship that they didn't clean that up up very good.
You know,
they shoveled it out and they left a lot of stuff and they just painted over it.
Of course,
when it was started to sail that ship,
buckling and everything and that
cal drop and just deliver word,
you know,
and the bunk were stacked up eight high.
And I was lucky.
I was small enough to get in there without any trouble is a lot of those little
guys at in and the head,
uh,
you know,
the Navy and Marine Corps.
Then the bathroom is called the head,
you know,
uh,
the head was just alone shed from the bowels of the ship back to the,
holdings,
you know,
where the captain students,
so forth and what had happened.
They'd made it a tree.
Uh,
what would the dream of what
a terrible for water would flow down the thing,
right?
Then they had a pipe for you to sit on,
whether you just sit on that pipe and then,
uh,
do you thing and get up and leave,
you know.
Well,
that thing broke down.
And so here we were,
I see a with no way to dispose of,
uh,
you know,
the droppings.
Well.
Anyway,
so the Dutch captains,
Sandy,
this crude set,
uh,
make things on the front of this bow of the ship and it kind of like saddle of,
the oldest one,
the side of a horse,
you know,
you just go up,
burn,
drop your pants and sat down on that thing and,
and dog feed the fish,
you know,
well,
hours to bias before we go out and use that because there were 13 naval nurses
on that same ship and they set up and I held off.
I was trying to hold off or dark writers too embarrassed to go,
but finally I had to go shot him for no burden to drop a package like the rest
of them did.
Well,
yeah.
You know,
when you're floating along,
you're going up and down.
First thing you know,
you're,
yeah,
but it's in the water and it comes back hat on.
And uh,
you didn't really need toilet paper because you didn't need them because it
wasn't in on there.
That was a problem the whole time I was in the Marine Corps overseas was toilet
paper.
Oh,
that was something,
but that's the way we traveled there.
And,
uh,
when you go through the hour,
sea sick,
our seasick all the time,
they put me in a,
in the sick bay and for some reason there were a box or high whole crackers in
there.
I don't know what it was doing on a troop ship,
but there were so wrong.
And so I'd eat a couple of those ever hour and they'd hide them or nobody else
can get them.
And we're just on that ship for 29 days to get the New Caledonia.
And,
uh,
one day the ship broke down here were our drifted,
not drifted for all,
probably 30 or 40 hours,
you know,
and we was taking bets as where we are drift too and South America and,
and they,
they get past the word out that we're just fortunate to keep her laugh,
bail tall on at all times and keep your eyes looking out for,
okay.
So submarines cause we didn't have any escort,
we were just out there by herself and number slow cattle ship.
And uh,
we was in real trouble and,
and we'd drifted for 72 hours and they finally got the engine going again.
So here we are going to overseas.
We didn't know where we're going,
you know,
and uh,
then we got a scare that there was possibly a jap submarine in the area.
So we pulled into the nearish
okay.
We were close to,
you know,
we pulled in there and I fell in love without that island.
It was,
uh,
Tonga to pool and we just went in one of these things you see in the movies,
you know,
and we pulled in that bay and dropped anchor and here the natives came out
paddling canoes and they had a coconut pineapple,
a lot of fruit and stuff.
And so I'm up our to us and then we fast for those things.
Well,
anyway,
they came,
came back that night and entertained us on the deck of the ship.
We sitting around there and they were
doing their dances,
a hula dances,
and it was a beautiful island.
How many is beautiful?
And I swore,
rutter,
I said to myself,
Fred Harvey is a lot more in this world,
in Odessa,
Texas,
and I'm going to see some of it before I die.
And so they put on a show and it lasts.
They Sung there island song,
you know what it was,
you are my sunshine.
And we pulled away from Myron.
We got started,
then we stopped,
went back,
well,
what's going on?
Six guys had jumped shield.
He went ashore,
arm,
forearm,
back.
Well,
I didn't think about jumping ship for,
I'd thought about it.
I might've them.
And so we pulled out and finally got to a,
uh,
New Caledonia.
He'd been at sea for 29 days.
And uh,
we as all tickled to finally get the,
but that ship was a hail she up.
And uh,
when we got there,
it took us off to she up.
And this is now in New Caledonia.
You killed it on,
it's a year or a couple months out of bootcamp at this point.
Yeah.
Okay.
And is this the first place you stop and you're going to basically just for
people that don't know,
you're going to get to New Caledonia and you're going to kind of train and
prepare for,
for going out and taking down some islands?
Yeah,
well,
it was two reasons he went there.
We
go on a farm up with,
uh,
rest of the troops.
You know,
the first parachute battalion was already there.
In fact,
they were involved in Guadalcanal and,
uh,
so,
we were going down and out and replace.
The guys
went to the first parachute battalion.
They were 60 miles from,
uh,
the base we came in on.
Uh,
I can't remember the base that we landed at out of the port.
We landed that,
but,
uh,
it was a capital of New Caledonia and are the parachute battalions were
stationed out.
Oh,
about 60 miles from,
uh,
you may,
you may have as a capital of a place.
And then once you got,
does that,
where you met your,
your,
that where you joined up,
you're saying with your parachute company?
Yeah.
I was assigned to the first parachute battalion in,
did you,
if I remember correct,
did you go to Guadalcanal this at this point?
No.
Uh,
we went later when we went up to
our first action together after Guata canal was,
uh,
we supposed to go to the Belo Lavella and said,
we're on our way up.
We stopped off at,
uh,
Guadalcanal and
Guadalcanal had been,
uh,
secured,
you know,
and so they let a scrimmage,
we went up to find some of the old guys that had
escaped.
The Japanese
had escaped and we didn't see anything,
so we didn't get to shoot any jabs.
So we were there,
uh,
all a couple of days.
And,
uh,
we got up for child one morning just about before sunup never thing.
And I was up front of the line.
I'd always managed to get the front of the line for Chow.
Yeah,
for child.
You've mentioned throughout the book that year,
a guy that liked your chow.
Oh,
I love challenge.
I was trying to catch up with the hunger.
I'll had been during the depression.
Well anyway,
we was in line waiting to go in and get cha,
you know,
and uh,
then I heard a lot of laughing and carrying on back to the lines.
So I ran under,
sees what the action was,
you know,
and there's three be Draggle Japanese had just come out of the line out of the
jungle and got in line
and uh,
and an officer got the,
came down and they could speak Japanese and they,
he said they were hungry and everything,
so they took them apart and fed them and they kept him there I guess as long as
they needed them.
They was washing pots and pans and doing work there when we left and so forth.
They got off light.
And um,
so as you were preparing to go,
now you're working at you,
you had a couple of guys that you mentioned in the book.
You know,
I'll start with the first one.
I'm going to mention three of them.
Uh,
Major Fagan,
faith forgotten is that he Sagan,
Sagan,
Major Fagan.
He sounds like one tough customer.
He was to,
ah,
man he was,
I was scared.
I'd see him coming down,
you know,
the trail or anything like that.
I jumped into the jungle,
keep with me cause I was scared of him.
Well everybody was scared of him because he was tough.
He just drove,
uh,
he found out that Japanese march,
full packs and a 24 hour period,
March 39 miles,
he said,
we're going to beat that.
And we marched 50 miles.
We're full tax,
uh,
down New Caledonia and we would walk up the heels and trot down the healed.
It came down and we went 50 miles.
And uh,
I don't know whether it's any kind of record book,
her name,
Tang,
but we,
we're proud of it,
so forth.
It's a record book either,
but I know it hurt.
Now you also did a couple of you tell a couple stories in the book about him.
Um,
but he,
he was,
he had no problem putting people on bread and water.
Oh,
no problem.
No problem.
In fact,
I was put it on bread and water.
I had a buddy there
went through the parachute per tune with me.
Right.
Tiny.
He nearly got us killed thing,
I won't give him his name,
you know,
but he passed away several years ago.
I don't want to say anything.
We don't want to incriminate his ass.
Well he uh,
when we was going through parachute school,
his name,
well I'll tell you his name,
uh,
last name,
his name was Harmon.
So when we land up alphabetically and everything we did,
you know,
well he was always right behind me.
So when we went to a parachute school,
we wound up together,
you know,
because of her name's being real close to one another.
Well,
anyway,
uh,
now
when we jumped to bring cord jumps from the plane,
we dove out head first.
Their theory was that when you jump out and that parachute opens your eye to
eye,
he kind of swaying with a,
well the army jumped him out feet first and came down so forth.
So we jumped,
we jumped out head first while we were training there and uh,
out here and Camp Gillespie.
That's where the parachute school laws
and um,
we lined up to make our first jump will harm Harmon rows behind me.
Well in the plane we had,
we called it the blue goose.
Now we had to borrow that from the navy because Marine Corps didn't,
I wouldn't any planes sale.
So we used the blue goose.
So they took us out there and a truck,
you know,
the guys that had volunteered to go into the parachute school and that truck
driver Dover's out tired and uh,
and the barks and the officers didn't,
everything was on top of this hill and below was the a runway.
And that's where the,
where we jumped into that area or a tow truck driver drove up bar and stop real
fast.
She said they're fixing job.
Do you guys want to watch?
And so we all jumped out of the truckers.
There's about 10 or 15 of us,
you know,
jumped out of the truck,
watch him.
They flew over,
man.
Here they come dive and out one,
I'm pushing.
It was coming down fast.
[inaudible] like this,
his parachute didn't open.
And so just before he hit the deck,
that parachute opened.
He had to pull out of this.
It is,
uh,
reserves shoot.
Now the reserve chute was on the front and it didn't have a pilot chute on it.
So when you pull a rip parties sports,
pull out that SilkAir sale [inaudible] was now alone.
He is pulling that out.
Just he got bailed out,
he hit the deck and a jeep was on its way down there and they put him in the
jeep,
put a parachute on him,
got him out on the plane,
the plane,
one of burn out.
He came again.
And that truck driver said,
any of you guys want to go back to boot camp?
And two guys got back on the truck and I thought seriously about it.
And uh,
yeah,
that's not a good initiation into parachute jumping,
that's for sure.
Yeah,
well we had to pack our own shoot.
We learned how to pack,
shoot,
we,
and every step you took a parachute school you had to be running.
If you weren't running and offer an NCO or at Kashi you,
you were in trouble.
You know.
So every step we took,
we learned how to pack shoots,
ran up and down.
I got where I could pack a chute and 12 minutes.
Okay,
well one day they said,
you're going to pack a shoot today and you're going to jump to tomorrow.
And I said,
uh Oh,
I better take a little bit more time.
So it took me 30 minutes.
Do that
well that night,
uh
Oh,
what was that Indian,
his name.
But uh,
it was a paper.
Hayes.
All right.
Hey,
he was in my platoon.
You heard of our pay,
his hip raised the flag on the Eagle.
He was real quiet and there was another end in,
in there with him.
And that night before we jumped,
that guy jumped off and hollered,
Gung Ho,
you know,
and broke both of his ankles.
So that ended his parachute.
But our,
oh,
was he was,
he was a good Barain.
He's quiet,
you know,
he never,
never said much.
And I'd talk to him,
you know,
cause my mom was a Comanche Indian and I had some Indian blood,
and not tell him that,
you know,
and,
and we became close friends,
but he's so quiet.
She know great,
great guy.
But he,
this is quiet.
Whether you know the history of what he did,
what happened to avoid guy?
Yeah.
Well anyway,
we came out and at first jump we made,
we made the jump
and when I came out,
I dove out.
When my chute opened,
I was standing on another shoot below me was Harmon.
He should've been the bug me cause he's coming out of there.
We didn't think much about it.
You know,
I just started jumping was like,
well the next day we jumped again and we came up,
we were tangled together
and uh,
and their suits,
you know,
when they're slanting up,
like at air was going up too fast,
you know,
when holding the Sheba,
the brain and when we hit
like a ton of bricks hit and you know,
man,
it hurt and everything cause that she hadn't,
wasn't able to,
those shoes weren't able to hold us up.
So we hit the ground pretty hard to the jump masters and the guy on the deck
watching thing,
they just,
what happened,
and I don't know,
they didn't ask anything of Harmon.
You know,
he's always made me looking at,
you know,
well anyway,
when in fact it was looking at me because I didn't even have boots on the one
dominant,
where's your boots?
I said they all don't have any,
they were fit.
So they finally got me a pair or a six size and told me to wear four pair of
socks,
you know,
first boots ahead,
went back to Harmon.
Well,
the next time we jump I came out bruised up and everything when we're jump will,
uh,
I was
my shoot,
uh,
at,
the shroud lines had channel tangled up in my boot,
you know,
so I whipped up k bar knives and cut those two strategies,
uh,
rope,
you know,
to let me down just before I hit the ground wield,
I got my feet down first,
you know,
and they'd come running over to me.
And what are they going on there?
What's happening?
I don't know.
And so
what did it happened when my parachute,
when I jumped out our dove out of the thing,
right?
I was facing a plane and my Sadie Klein was playing out between my legs.
And so that's a foot got tangled up in the shroud lines,
man.
They came up there and they decided I was too light to be in and uh,
in a parachute,
you know.
And so the sergeant over there at the,
at the loft where we
packed our shoots,
you know,
he and a officer would talk and he said,
well,
he just too light.
And,
and I were standing there talking about,
I said,
y'all can't kick me out.
I want to stay in this outfit.
I wanted to stay in it.
And so that sergeant,
he said,
why don't we put him in a army navy canopy.
Now the army,
Navy canopy was only 26 feet diameter.
And the ones we use denial on,
no one's users,
28,
just a bigger canopy and everything.
So this guy took an army navy parachute,
took it out and put it on me.
Uh,
all the cage,
you know,
we get what they call it,
where he folded,
you shoot and put it on there.
And so here I am with a,
with a parachute,
you know,
made out of silk and instead of nylon and a cl cl react a lot faster than nylon
does.
So.
So when that she'd opened,
I got a pretty good
kick out of it.
Well,
when we came out and that day we were going to jump with weapons and so they
gave us all a rise in gun.
You ever heard of horizon gun?
No.
Oh,
it was about as worthless.
The grease gun.
So we called it a grease gun.
It was a terrible weapon.
They uh,
they outlawed him in the,
in the military right quick.
Well,
anyway,
I had one of those and uh,
when I went out the door,
Harmon hit me and knocked my bride and gun down and it went down to stuck into
the garden and they,
they,
uh,
this is our fourth job.
And uh,
and the sergeant said they were,
they were considering just really dropped me,
send me back to the bootcamp to be signed somewhere else,
you know,
uh,
with tears in my,
I begged them,
let me stay,
you know.
Well,
and then the sergeant said,
I'm going to go up
tomorrow and watch and see what is happening.
And uh,
so he went up there and found out what was happening here.
We'd come and down this white line and the fuselage of the plane and then the
white line was raw,
authentic,
leading out the door.
So we were supposed to come down and make a sharp turn and dive out while I was
coming down and going out to the proper way.
Harmon was coming down there and he was cutting across and he was going through
the doors,
same time I was,
and it was knocking me against the side over there.
And,
and he just knocked me out.
He was shooting,
was opening for mine,
was opening.
And so we got that straightened out and uh,
and that wasn't the only trouble I had with Harmon,
but that's a different story.
Or maybe I shouldn't bring it up here.
So
you actually,
you actually talk about when you did find the,
get your first jump,
everything went good.
And you said,
you know,
I had never made first string in any sport because of my size,
but when they pin those wings on my chest and shoved a rifle into my hands,
I had a last made first string.
That rifle in my hands size no longer seemed relevant.
I had made the team and found a home,
the marine corps filled all my dreams and all my needs.
Harmon actually ended up getting you in trouble.
Yeah.
Right while you were in New Caledonia.
Well I won't go into the pink house,
but I do in the book going on.
I don't know.
Our Day off was Wednesday first got Wednesday off.
You know,
they didn't let us all off.
It's the same time because they didn't what one another Pearl Harbor top thing,
because the Japs were still on the offensive at that time.
So,
uh,
he,
he got where he would go down there every Wednesday and,
uh,
he fell in love with one of those girls and they fell in love with it or she
fell in love with him,
but he went in there and he didn't get the bus,
but last truck going back to base and he didn't get back in,
so he had to hitchhike.
I don't know how he got there,
but he got are about,
oh,
about an hour after roll call and everything.
So when he showed up,
well Fagan just put him on five days.
Bread and water.
Fagan don't play around.
Yeah.
Well when you buy it would buy us something over from the px.
He couldn't go in and buy one bar candy or one can of beans or anything.
Like you had to buy a whole box.
Okay.
So on his third day I went,
went over and got me,
uh,
Joe boy.
Now Joe Boyd was a non chocolate,
you couldn't have chocolate candy in the tropics because it melts,
you know,
so they had this new get,
uh,
covered with the peanuts and is called Joe Board.
So I went by there one night and I opened up not as eating.
One of them hollered at him through the Barb wire thing.
He was in a tent and it was kind of in a clearing in the woods,
you know,
he said,
Harvey told me one of those things,
I haven't had anything but bread and water for three days now.
I said,
no,
I'm not going to tell you I was against the rules.
I'll come on please.
I would do it for you.
And just kept going.
So I looked around,
took two of them out and fill a carp.
Birla Gorg Fagan had seen me
when he came over and he said,
put this guy in the,
and uh,
art fairs happened to be the corporate of the guard at that time.
And he said,
well,
we can't,
we're all packed up.
They're just one,
uh,
bunk.
Uh,
Gotcha.
What feeling you got caught in there and the rest of them are all packed and
ready to go.
And he said,
there's no place for him to sleep.
He said,
what?
Take that guy out and put the guy in there.
And so the next day I'm sitting there and I was all ready,
had a couple of loaves of bread and water.
He came by with a box of candy.
I said,
come on and fill me more than little things.
I though he says,
no,
that's against the rules.
I don't want to get in trouble.
Oh,
he never did throw one little word to me.
Cold blooded.
Yeah.
How you were going to get sort of written up for that.
Um,
and Lieutenant Hall,
who you know you,
you got a lot of Spec for.
I'm going back to the book here.
He,
they said,
now you're checking in with the hall and he's supposed to write you up and put
this in your permanent record and he says,
Harvey,
he said with a document in hand,
I was ordered to write you up but I can't put it in your records.
Has All our records had been stowed away to remain here.
I'll have to carry this paper with and it will surely get lost in the jungle
before we get back to civilization again.
I got a knowing smile and a pat on the back.
Now get outta here.
Be and forget what has happened.
Get your gear in order.
I think we're taking a boat ride.
I gave him the smartest solution possible and said,
thank you sir.
I appreciate what you've done for me.
I think I might've skipped to my tent filled to the deep joy and the
deliciousness of being a marine.
I left my troubles behind me and soon got to feel the thrill of combat.
I realized soon after in the heat of battle that the harsh demanding training of
that Major Richard Fagan sergeant ought Ferris and Lieutenant Ralph F.
Hall put us through,
paid off.
We performed well under fire.
Ferris and Fagan received wounds in the battle of Iwo Jima.
Lieutenant Hall died in the Battle of Iwo Jima.
I shed bitter tears when I heard the news of his death.
He was a great marine at IIE.
Will Fagan earn the navy cross as we fought for Bogan Ville,
Sergeant Ferris did some amazing things for which he received the coveted silver
star.
Later at the battle for Evo,
he earned the bronze star and purple heart medals.
Then he went on to win his second Silver Star and purple heart during the Korean
War.
Heck,
this guy hung around to fight in the Vietnam,
in Vietnam in the 1960s a marine,
a marine's marine.
I found serving with him a great honor.
One of the high points of my life,
even today,
70 plus years later,
we get together from time to time.
What do we talk about?
Of course,
the war and our buddies,
that bygone era.
So you had,
I thought that was just a great leadership story about how Lieutenant Hall just
said,
Hey,
you know what?
We're gonna,
we're gonna shred this document and it's not,
it never happened.
And then you move to your first,
was it your first combat was being in Bogan Ville?
Uh,
no.
Velo.
Velo was.
Okay.
Yeah.
And what,
what was,
uh,
what was going into Bella Bella,
Bella,
what was it?
Vella.
Lavella Vella.
Lovell.
Lavella.
Well,
yeah,
no,
we were island hopping over there.
What we would do would evade an island,
put it in an air strip and a thing and to use to hop to the next island,
cause it didn't when we were through and it's nearly vacated and they're loud.
They airfield it,
reuse you,
but he didn't ever thing.
And so Bella Bella was,
uh,
one of those stages and everything.
And across the bay there,
I think something like 13 miles or something was colon Ben Garra.
Now that was just an island,
just sticking up,
a volcanic island sticking up in the ocean.
And it was,
uh,
all the jab occupied it.
And uh,
but we took Vela Vela and put it in an air strip there.
We landed there.
And that was when I had my first taste of action.
Uh,
we moved in to the island,
to the jungle and they,
CBS,
we're supposed to follow us in,
you know,
and start building there,
or the cvs or the tough outfit.
They were getting ahead of us and we'd had,
she owned bank.
So they made an ask us,
get on the,
it's not a,
uh,
their tractors.
And that's what we did.
And the other thing.
But,
um,
then we moved when we were moving out at the beach where we send out of the arm
patrolled because we had a,
when we invaded,
we didn't run into any jabs,
but we found that there were some up our,
so we were going to go up and then attack them before they could get down and,
and work over the seabees that we're building the air strip,
you know.
And so it was so hot in the jungle was so thick.
We had to have a guy's using match.
It's,
you know,
to,
to chop our way through there.
Well,
we last only about 10 minutes
using those shoppers.
We get through there.
It just big blades,
you know,
just use,
uh,
you just shopped through the vines.
Well,
we were staggered.
The guy was here,
I was here and another guy was here and we were working our way through it.
And uh,
and the JAP Nambuu opened up on us and this jap was up in a tree and he shot and
killed these two guys.
It was in this line over here and I was over here.
So they didn't get us get it all three of us.
Well anyway,
then he went out to me and I just jumped under those threads and uh,
uh,
the brush and everything and I just crawled one place or other than,
and I don't think he could see me,
but he was proud to see the leaves and branches working.
He is firing at me and everything.
And so,
uh,
a guy,
a big guy,
I had an aide for machine gun,
you know,
that's an Eric [inaudible] 30 caliber weapon and he had an asbestos glove and he
was big enough and strong enough that he could fire short bust at a time with it
and everything.
So he said,
Harvey,
what tree is that guy?
And I said,
that big one over here on the left,
he said,
that
doesn't mean a thing.
They're all big and on the left and right.
And so I said,
fire at one of them rot,
Darnell,
I'll give you directions where to go.
So,
uh,
at got fired at me and they saw the,
where he was shooting up.
So this guy,
I wish I could think of his name,
big guy.
I admired him because he was big and strong,
but he just saturated that thing that a four machine gun and sure enough here
came a jap hanging.
He had a rope around his foot and that,
uh,
Nambuu machine gun,
that's the first zap weapon I'd seen as the first time I'd been shot at,
you know,
so I remember the NAM move real well.
Well,
anyway,
uh,
um,
what was my first action and man,
I hated those jap machine guns,
but if I had to go to war right now,
I would get me a Jap nambuu machine gun and there's a picture of that weapon was
something else.
And she had a magazine and hold 20 shells and boots and I ran across another one
and he will gima nuts.
Another story.
And,
but uh,
and then,
then you guys pretty much mopped up that first operation and there wasn't too
much resistance.
Now they went in too much resistance and then the,
and then you moved on after that.
Was that when you had it to Bogan Ville?
Is that the next place we went to Bogan veil.
After that you got an interesting story in about uh,
about Bogan Ville.
That kind of,
I think it's worse.
Might be worth talking about a little bit because it's kind of shows how,
you know,
war is not always what it's made out to be in the movies.
Um,
so here we're going you,
you are actually speaking of toilet paper and in this particular situation you
were just done.
Get it done.
You'd gone to relieve yourself,
buy a little house and then you hear the order.
I heard the order move out on the double as I stood between the house and the
Banyan tree,
buckling my belt,
something in the vague misty light caused caught my eye.
I stood in wrapped amazement as a guy came diligently down the tree.
I could see that he had only a piece of cloth around his waist.
When he reached the bottom,
he bent forward as if to pick up a sandal.
I watched an utter wonderment as this scene played out before me.
Just a little guy.
When he straightened up,
I stepped up and brought my rifle stock across the back of his head with a
glancing blow.
He turned as he crumpled and landed fully on his back.
I looked down and to my horror,
I found myself looking at a female instead of a male stoned and shaken by my
act,
I choked on a Saab and trembled uncontrollably.
What had I done?
As I stood there,
bathed and pity and compassion,
all hell broke loose.
The shatter and clatter of small arms fire broke the silence,
trying hard to choke back the sobs.
I raced to join the firefight.
Glad to leave that pitiful pathetic scene and act and outnumbering force.
Pin this down all day,
although desperately busy.
During this time,
my thoughts kept going back to the base of that Banyan tree.
At mid day our ammunition ran low.
The sergeant ordered me back to the rear to find more.
I veered from a direct path to the beach to pass by that tree of infamy.
I found neither her nor her body.
I quickly ran around the tree and under the house to no avail.
I had ventured up the steps to look inside the house.
Inside.
It looked like an infirmary or aid station,
but empty.
I hope that I'd only stunned her and she had walked away from the area.
After the incident.
I gave a great deal of thought to that lady in the Coconut Grove,
definitely of Oriental heritage.
I wondered her purpose there.
I thought of several possibilities she could have served as a nurse in the
Japanese military or a resident of the island.
Brought there by the late lever brothers soap company to work in the coconut
groves.
Also,
she might come from Korea,
one of the many Korean women kidnapped by the jabs to serve as prostitutes for
their military.
No matter the reason I hope and pray that she survived the blow to her head and
the war in my lifespan.
I've stored many,
many items in my arsenal of memories.
The memory of that day so very long ago.
Rest among my most vivid,
the memorable events on that lonely beach on the far side of planet earth have
not dimmed over time nor distance.
It all took place because I crawled beneath the house.
Okay.
I think I lost the last vestige of the little boy within me that day.
Yeah.
That was really tough on me.
You know,
I remember my sisters,
you know,
and,
and thought bad.
Terrible.
It would be if they were hit like that.
And it stuck with me all of these years.
You know,
I remember that little,
the lady in that jungle,
that was another story.
Uh,
there we were sitting up bar.
What was the name of that beach?
Corey.
Corey beach.
We had heard that the Jap or a fiction and come up by her.
So it was,
he sent first,
but tie in up bar and a company of Raiders at buyer.
We went a bar,
left our base at about 12 o'clock and it's 12 miles up the island.
And when we invaded,
they did it during the night.
We waited until he began to get light.
Well,
there was a Japanese officer came in,
walked into the group.
I didn't see him cause I was out on the flank,
but it was a Japanese officer.
He came down,
Nag Hollerin instructions and everything and he didn't know it was marines.
It had come to shore.
He thought it was cause they were building up to invade that area where we're
building the airstrips,
you know,
and so they shot him dead rotten and all hell break loose because we were
outnumbered 10 to one.
And when I finished with doing my job and hurting that little girl,
well I ran the kitchen with a bunch,
you know,
well the first car caught up with him,
why did he mains?
And he was in my company and everything.
So we went on an apparent and we use on the very end the flank and uh,
we both had Johnson rifles and that's all we had to protect that flank with.
And that's a weak part of the line.
And Hall came up there or I'd say about nine or 10 o'clock,
he said,
uh,
what do you all doing down here?
You're supposed to be up there with us.
And they'd gone on up there and we've worked a B company.
We were with B Company and a company was in the middle of the,
of the group,
you know.
And so he just said,
well stay here and I'll get,
get a name for down here,
protect this blank.
You know,
the flank is a weak point in the line,
said Y'all protect it.
Whether it was a coconut grove that we hit into and they had a road behind that
coconut grove and those Japs were using that whole material up power to invade
that airstrip.
And so here,
why the,
and our own the flank that and that's where we're detecting whether they began
to send,
uh,
planes a diner and they would stray from that road,
that we were,
uh,
struck out alone,
you know,
and those planes were coming hard and fast and fat and to come up our
protectors,
they don't have wiped us out cause it a whole regiment of Jeff [inaudible]
fixing to invade that deal.
Dot Day.
And those planes were coming just one after another and it didn't even bother to
put up the landing gears.
They just left them down and we'd come along.
Strafe nude drop bombs along the way.
And we were on the very end.
We,
we've afraid there's going to start,
they're shooting for,
they got to,
we'd get out there and wave,
I don't rotten and they'd go buy signal wave at us and start strafing.
And uh,
we were there all day long and uh,
and the commander down at,
uh,
at the dire just told him to,
to,
uh,
sending it up,
crafts to take us off and vegans answered,
no,
we're not going to be the first man,
uh,
marines to be pushed off of a beach.
We were scheduled to be taken off at seven o'clock and that's when we will start
boarding oh boat.
So we was out all day long and it was a long day and haul.
It came up are few times and we've had Johnson rifles.
We didn't have the n one rifle.
We had Jerry Johnson.
Ralph was a 30 caliber,
a cylinder fed.
Uh,
they didn't even use clips in them.
Not Thought it was the best weapon that I had besides in the,
in the war,
beside the Nambuu and a hollowed bring us ammunition up there.
And then he finally come up there late in the afternoon.
He said,
you guys make this last cause there's,
we're nearly out of ammunition.
And so here we were and we couldn't do anything until seven o'clock.
So ships,
Higgins boats were out there circling,
waiting for seven o'clock,
I guess,
because then,
uh,
odd fairs came up and he said,
now we're going to be taken off.
And we started at seven o'clock and that's about an hour and a half from now.
And the guys next to you,
they're in company B now
because of the mix up.
You know why he remains.
And I was involved in,
well,
anyway,
uh,
at first told us,
said,
when these guys over here,
they're going to leave and when they leave,
they're going to Holler and let you know that they're leaving.
You count to 50 as fast as he can and then get down to the beach.
Okay.
So we sit there and we sit there.
We hear these boats coming in and taking off and uh,
shooting and everything on it right there.
I said,
why did he,
Gosh,
what time is,
uh,
we should be getting out of here and everything and why did you shed hollered
over our,
those other guys,
right.
Done.
They didn't answer us.
So I walked over there and they'd already lived and didn't call it out.
So here we were,
only two guys left on the beach,
I guess.
And we started running a lot of,
it's pretty fast.
So I took,
uh,
why this uh,
Johnson rifle and I cared both of them down there and it's still beat him down
to the bus.
I mean,
who the
Higgins boat.
But it wasn't the Higgins boat.
It was a,
okay,
it was a one l CVP.
Oh,
CVT is heavier than the Higgins boat is all steel.
Right?
So here we are running down there and Hollerin don't leave it on leave and
everything.
Well,
odd Ferriss was on the deck and uh,
and the ramp on that LSV was at about a 45 degree angle because that was taking
shots from the Japs.
And Out Ferris was,
they'd done.
Now he and uh,
and uh,
uh,
Captain Hayes,
he captained by this time he was trying to hold us up and everything.
And Fagan was on that boat and this little toxin on the thing right there.
I said,
we're moving out.
We leave and not a Vegan city.
Forties,
we'd feed,
there's guys down there and put the pistol in that kids have put this back on.
I'm blow year bleep,
paid off,
we put it back on there and the guys that are around that they,
this telling us about what happened.
And so here we are running and so forth.
And I got down there and,
and unfair stucco's to Ralph and threw them up on up there into the boat and uh,
uh,
hall got them to the Lord a little bit throughout the thing.
And then,
uh,
unfair took us by our foot,
you know,
and he's just up there and haul full of this on the in and I got up burn here,
uh Oh,
why remains finally got there.
And uh,
that's how we got off the island.
But you held the line until seven o'clock yeah.
As you were ordered.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
it took about 30 to 40 minutes,
I guess to get everybody off there.
And we were the last two to get off the,
I don't know.
And uh,
I'd been on the beach before.
I didn't want to be on a beach again and Japanese territory.
Now,
once you got back on the boat or you got back out,
now the
next thing to do is prepare for you.
Oh,
well we got back,
uh,
okay.
They take shot.
We got back on a destroyer and which headed heading back in,
uh,
two,
and purser gutters bay.
That was on Bogan vls where we invaded if set up a script in order to attack New
Guinea.
But anyway,
uh,
we got the word,
I forget exactly when it got to that breaking up.
The paratroopers were just coming back to this stage.
Okay.
And so we got back to the states and
okay.
Well integrated into the fifth division.
Oh,
okay.
Well that's interesting that you do,
so that this is when you told the whole story about your mom coming to bring you
45.
This is when this is now happening.
Yeah.
That one.
And did you,
did you guys just sailed back to America?
Okay.
Yeah,
we came on back to America.
It was on liberty ship.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and they got
back to Pendleton and,
uh hmm.
We got a little leave.
I don't know how long it was.
It might've been 30 days leave,
you know,
and then we started farming up in the fifth division
and that's when I,
uh,
oh,
when we got back
hours,
uh,
I had,
what do you call,
uh,
the could,
you know,
I broke out all over the body.
It just like having athlete's foot on their whole body.
And,
uh,
so they brought us back and,
and then another story I might throw in here,
we were stationed over there at Camp Pendleton.
And,
uh,
we landed up one morning to go to chow,
you know,
it was still about half dark,
and we were standing there and,
and art fairs is out in front
and there's
a group come marching up there,
turned out to be women.
And uh,
yeah,
God first said,
well,
this,
this man's outfit is going to go into pots.
We have dogs in our,
and then we have this group in here and everything.
Now we've got women in here
shaking his head and then we heard holding her.
The guy up here said fire too for effect.
Another guy down here hollered back,
Bam,
and overwhelming,
nearly broke ranks.
Okay.
On out to those guys.
And I found out what Bam meant,
the broad ass marine,
and they then go for that.
It won't break Gregson come out of her room.
Uh,
that was when I first found out that there were women in the Marine Corps.
And so now you're preparing,
at this point,
you're preparing to go back overseas or with the fifth?
The fifth marines.
Yeah.
And your division,
or sorry,
fifth division,
which is in the 26th marines.
Got It.
And is this when you,
is this when you met Basil loan back here in California?
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
his group was over there at the chow line one time and several of the guys that
are just mashed it alone,
there's bashed alone.
Of course.
He was my,
he rode to,
you know,
so as soon as we got there,
land up there,
go into the Chow Hall,
I snuck over and I said,
sir,
can I shake your hand?
He certainly,
he shook my hand bag and that was my experience with now copper Darcia had told
me quite a bit about and loan because they were,
he was about how far did you say?
30 yards from bash loan when bachelor loan where's aren't in his,
uh,
Congressional Medal of honor.
You know,
he did the first enlisted man be awarded the Medal of honor and in the Marine
Corps and more war too.
Okay.
And uh,
and then,
uh,
you know,
he came back,
it was in prayed,
oh,
bond drives and so forth.
And he had it made,
but he wanted to get back to who?
The Marine Corps and work
okay.
With the Marines groups again.
So we joined up and came back and he got killed at,
he will Jima.
Okay.
Now was wasn't a,
and we'll get to that for sure.
It wasn't,
um,
well did I read that copper was actually chesty polars runner?
Yeah.
In Guam was at Guadalcanal water canal.
He was
talking about water canal all the time,
you know,
and I had never heard of the heart,
uh,
chesty puller Carbor shard telling him about it and there was a thing and uh,
cobber load that all of the marines load though chesty puller and uh,
I'd like to have served under it,
but are served under some good guys.
Uh,
Fagan was one of them.
He was,
uh,
you know,
he wasn't little like chesty puller waters,
but he was an efficient leader of man,
not that.
And then went to the w two.
You're back home in America for how long are you back home for getting ready to
head back over?
Well,
let's see.
Wasn't one too long,
you know,
they,
uh,
I had to go,
go over that.
I told you had to go to the hospital and be treated for,
we called it Japanese crud,
no Chinese crud.
And it was just breaking out,
you know,
kind of like I always started kinda like athlete's foot or with their whole
bodily and the only treatment they'd put some kind of blue medicine on this,
another thing.
And so I was over here in the bar bell ball hospital for nearly a month before I
was released from there or I got rid of,
there was a lot of us in that same position,
you know,
and then
back on another ship to head back overseas.
Well we trained over here for a couple of months and then
we,
uh,
we was trained up for,
to go overseas and we may,
uh,
practice invasion of one that is Lyle and is off,
off of here.
And we invaded it,
you know,
practicing.
And,
uh,
and when we got there,
we land up on the beach,
knew he kept sitting there waiting to be told to move on the end or something
that we set our and sit there and everything.
Finally,
the officers that came out and told her said,
hey,
we're going back on the ships.
We had an overseas he and,
and so we went back a board,
she up and went over here,
came over here to Camp Pendleton and started getting ready to go back overseas
again.
And that's when I asked my mother,
find me a pistol and she,
she came over.
And then what you do more training and kept target.
That's the big island of Hawaii.
Yeah.
Okay.
So your name was called Camp Tara Rural.
So we trained and I was us when I was assigned to an assault squad and,
uh,
it was a demolition guy in that thing
and that was quite an experience.
And uh,
let's see,
then we trained and got ready to go to,
to,
uh,
he will
and while we training there,
their camp tolerable on the big island,
you know,
Atlanta's up ever Tuesday.
No,
I mean Wednesday and give us two cans.
Oh,
lucky lager beer.
I didn't drink route,
but covered,
loved that beer.
And so I would give my to to him and he would take an hide those and drank his
two would the boys,
you know,
and he swore me to secrecy.
Don't you tell anybody that I got to,
so when he hit the island of [inaudible] Jima,
he was carrying 14 cans of beer.
Well anyway,
on the way over there,
I see there's a picture in your book and you got hit with a little demo Satchel
law,
but you say there's no demo in that saturates all beer beer.
And he threw away his a gas mask and had four cans of beer and that gas mass.
Oh,
that's what it was.
Gas Mask.
Dictator bag,
you know.
Well,
anyway,
uh,
we heard on the ship,
we listened to Tokyo rollers,
you know,
we like to listen to her because she played good music.
You know,
when she's supposed to be breaking our moat morale down.
But she was helping our morale.
Well,
she said,
well,
I hear that the marines,
but she always had heard that the little marines are going to be hitting one of
our islands soon.
And uh,
she said they better brang their yes.
Mass.
And we heard that,
you know,
and I said,
[inaudible] once you're going to do,
I'm going to shoot you.
And so
they didn't use gas gas on us.
Thank goodness.
Did you,
uh,
when do you find out back then,
when did you find out,
hey,
the target,
is he,
oh,
Gima that's where you're going.
When did you start getting that briefing and know where you're actually heading
was at once you're on board the ships?
Yeah,
we were on the board ship for,
well,
we've got a board ship
and we sailed around and we went over and made a couple of practice landings in
those islands.
And,
uh,
Hawaii,
you know,
and so we went ashore,
uh,
be anchored out at Pearl Harbor,
you know,
and they gave us three or four hours leave off the ships,
so it was a group of us together was bound in town here in Hawaii.
This is not Hawaii though,
is close.
Anyway,
anyway,
we were all then and,
and one of the guys in my group was walking around and,
and golf knows everything,
you know,
on the island and it's got
named Lucas.
It was in my group when was walking around,
he lived,
he said,
there's my cousin over there.
And so we went across the street and it was uh,
uh,
Lucas,
his cousin,
you know,
what was his name?
Jacqueline Lucas,
you know,
and so he stayed with us and walking around and everything and we say,
we got to go back to the ship.
And so we went back to her ship and Jacqueline and Lucas was still with us.
And when he went,
oh boy,
we got a board.
He went in and checked in.
He was on there about three days out.
I said,
uh,
I talking to the other Lucas,
you know.
So was he a civilian?
Was Jack was the cousin of civilian or was he had another marine or here's
another marine.
Lucas was marine.
And so he just wanted to board
with us and uh,
and he was there for about three days and I said,
you better take your cousin over there and tell him that he's not a board his
ship where you're supposed to be with his outfit.
He was going to be a replacement in a first division,
but he wound up in the fifth division.
What was
in the 26 marines?
Yeah,
26 marines with us.
And uh,
he,
uh,
he got hurt.
He threw himself on a hand grenade and our two hanger UNAIDS and saved him his
buddies,
you know,
and he got the congressional medal of honor.
You've probably seen or heard of him cause he,
and uh,
he was from Mississippi.
I forget the name of the town.
And I just thought I was going over to see this guy and in Georgia and I,
uh,
went through that town and,
and I got past it.
So I said,
I'm just go back and see old Lucas.
And so I'll turn around as the turnaround is going back as heard on the radio
that he had passed away during the night and that was the last I seen a heard of
him,
you know,
then,
um,
so you finished up your training in Hawaii.
Now is your next stop going to be?
Yeah,
he will.
Yeah.
Did you guys,
did you guys know what did the intelligence that you got paint the picture that
he will was going to be
a really,
really hard fight.
Did you guys know that going in?
We had no idea what was just another island.
But when,
uh,
when it got light and I looked around and saw all the battleships and,
and just
so you weren't any more nervous for that?
You just thought,
well,
I'm going to go do what I've done the last few times.
No hours,
Garrett today.
Fair enough.
Well,
you know,
uh,
odd fares and Captain Hall.
I reserved runner and I was telling him before I'd ever seen any action,
I said,
well,
I don't remember how it will be when we see action.
I,
I'm afraid it'll be scared to death.
And everything.
And Captain Hall said,
that's what you want to be.
You want to be scared to death.
He said he should be scared half to death.
And you know,
there's no meaning to that being scared half to death because I was just scared
half to death.
And a lot of times,
you know,
I'm still alive,
but they said,
when you're scared,
when they're taking sober at dumps,
adrenaline into your brain and to your muscles and you react and everything.
And I know that's what happens to me because when I got hurt,
I was,
uh,
knew what was going on and knew what I had to do,
but a steel just scared that I can be.
And that's what saved me.
I think.
Um,
three already.
Did you already get,
why'd you already been wounded at this point before you vote?
Who you wounded in any of the other,
uh,
on [inaudible] so you're still,
you're still as lucky as they come right at this point?
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
when wounded at all now copper had been wounded before we hit a will.
He had been wounded at Guadalcanal.
And,
uh,
he got,
that night,
that bass alone,
uh,
did his thing and he was all about 30 or 40 yards from bashed alone and on that
line,
you know,
and the shale hit him.
So they took him off and he had a lot of those guys got malaria and he had
malaria real bad,
and they took him to Australia
and there was a ship,
they're going back.
And he was so with that,
that wound that they hadn't been able to treat it because the navy took off with
all the,
the,
uh,
medical gear and everything.
So he actually didn't see a doctor until he got back to Australia.
And
so he went back,
got back to the states and he wouldn't take a discharge.
And they sent a corpsman back with him.
You know,
he just put it on a merchant ship going back.
It wasn't a navy ship at all.
The emergency,
if it was going by and that Korman said,
carver,
this is in your home to die and they're going to discharge you.
And,
uh,
so cover,
he said he didn't know whether to believe that Korman or not,
but they sent him up to till them my Gargen and uh,
there was,
they had a balloon station up,
uh,
you know,
they put big balloons up in the area or we own cables,
to protect areas,
you know,
uh,
military areas.
The Japanese would probably sleep if they tried to invade us.
So he got in with a cross bill Krause up at time and a guy named halls fly.
He hosts flower,
I can't think of his name,
but he's from Wichita falls and we nicknamed the horse flies.
He's always talking about horses.
Well,
anyway,
uh,
they were up our garden,
a naval base at Tillamook,
Oregon,
and they was trying to get back,
uh,
fleet marines,
you know,
and they wouldn't send them.
So they was doing things that they shouldn't be doing.
They wrecked the jeep and that brought it to a head and they said,
here,
going back there to a rifle company.
So that's the way he got back in to the rifle.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's,
that's where you want those guys that are out wrecking jeeps.
Put 'em right back and rifle company.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I'd,
I was,
when I was putting in the hospital where the Chinese crud and,
and lost,
uh,
contact with my outfit and so forth and wind up with a,
nails Copeland.
And,
uh,
in the barracks over there,
there's nearly empty.
And so,
uh,
I went over and checked in and,
Copeland was the sergeant in charge and he was the only guy in the whole
barracks.
And I said,
where is,
everybody said,
well,
this is emptied out.
We were waiting to fill up again.
He said,
just go down there and find the bunk anywhere in the end.
I said,
well,
what room do you want me to be in it?
Well,
the lower floor,
they said they're not three or four guys down and I anyway,
take any and they bunk you won't,
you know.
So I've fooled around our and ate supper and everything and,
and got in in the bunk,
hung my uniform on the end of the bunk on the hanger.
And uh,
okay.
And I was sound asleep
and about 10 o'clock lights went on and all these guys are hollering,
saying,
and then everything right there,
I said,
you guys knock it off and turn out that light.
Who said that big boy
who said that?
Like I said,
I said,
I get those last turned off and here he comes over a warrior warriors.
So He'd come down there,
he was going to fight me.
So I jumped over that bunk order,
mad enough to fight anybody.
So here he come.
He was not much bigger than I was,
you know,
because he been hurt,
and everything.
And he saw my uniform and I had my ribbons on [inaudible],
hey,
you're a combat marine,
welcome aboard.
Come on over here.
And we got some,
uh,
some sandwiches and some beer and so forth.
Come on over here and join us.
I said,
I'll eat a sandwich so I don't drink beer.
And so that's how I met cupboard doors.
And,
uh,
we'd go on liberty together and
okay.
And they liked their booze and uh,
and horsefly I liked his booze too.
And he,
he drank pretty heavily.
So the Windup,
I didn't drink,
so I haven't just take care of horse fly and they would add dates and he hadn't
cross covering costs would go off to somewhere and I had to take,
uh,
care of a horsefly while we,
we were out in alieve Grover someplace here in
post to San Diego,
I guess what is closer to La I guess.
And we couldn't find a taxi or anything and I didn't know what to do.
I couldn't find a place to stay with him and everything.
So it was an all night movie going on showing porno films.
So we went in there and we won't went to sleep,
woke up next morning.
Films were still showing.
So I got him out.
We finally got home or back to camp and,
uh,
my experience with Hall Sfla a housefly was killed and he will and a cover and,
okay.
And Carlos were wounded too.
Uh,
let's see,
I end the book.
I told him how to copper was wounded,
didn't,
uh,
yeah,
you did.
That's a,
that's,
you want to hear that now?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
You hit the beach at,
I mean let's,
let's just take it from you.
You hit the beach at,
at,
at he will.
And I mean you weren't the landing at Iie.
Whoa.
Relative to some of the other landings at the Marine Corps done at this point
was,
well,
I mean,
what was your,
what was your
well,
low for an,
the Japanese always tried to stop us before we got to the beach and he will,
they let us get on the beach and that's when they really opened up with
everything to had,
you know,
and uh,
and it was
more effective than trying to stop this before we got to the beach or we were on
the beach and,
and a lot of officers and NCL was where kills,
you know,
off the beach.
So here we are laying on the beach and,
and it sloped and guidance were laying down on that thing.
And when were smarter Shit,
uh,
Marcell coming in like land raindrops when they'd hit.
And this explosion goes out and up.
You know,
what did,
we was all laying on the ground and not resist inviting those shelves to come in
and close to us,
you know,
and,
and so congress said,
we got to get off this off this beat.
So we started
hollering,
get off the beach run.
So we ran,
man,
I ran.
And the first thing,
you know,
all along the beach on the other side,
that's when I realized there's only little line.
And uh,
so we got over there and,
and,
and uh,
I heard that hall,
it had been killed on the boat.
And I cried because I loved that man.
I mean,
he treated me like a son and art fairs had been wounded too,
but,
uh,
hallway got it off right on the beach and one of those sales and got him.
And I was,
uh,
we,
we got over there and,
and it wasn't,
they weren't firing in that area.
So we spread out waiting for somebody to come or to take over.
You know,
we didn't know what to do.
So I was laying are propped up against a deal and I heard a shot real close to
us and everything.
I looked around and uh,
and I couldn't see anybody shooting,
you know,
and then looked over about 20 to 30 yards as a piece of tn raised up.
And,
uh,
Ralph would come out,
shot some,
made it another shot show.
I told him the guy in and over next to me and he had a riot gun.
We called them.
It was a 12 gauge shotgun with just a few balls and a,
uh,
cadre is,
you know,
I said,
come on,
follow me.
He said,
where are we going?
I said,
we're going to go over and have some fun.
So I said,
as a sniper in this whole,
under this piece of tea and I'm going to raise that up and you just shoot to
shoot in there.
And so I raised a Jap,
looked upon that guy,
cut loose.
We're about shotgun,
about tap far.
What'll Masset well that God never seen.
Nice.
And before with how the shotgun he threw up.
And,
uh,
but that's,
that's the first real thing I did on,
uh,
on the will
you,
a couple things that I wanted to just real quick ask about.
One of them was you,
you described in the book how the ground was literally hot from like the lava
and it was uncomfortable to lie down on,
couldn't lay on the scholar,
the it's steam heat coming from up to that volcanic ash.
You know,
they keep talking about the sands of Iie will gym.
I wasn't saying that was,
it was ash volcanic ash.
It was like BB size,
the old,
and it's
not saying
yeah.
And it was literally too hot to lay down on a lot of places and it was too cold.
I was going to say,
you know,
in the military we always get the worst of both worlds.
Yeah.
And you end,
it was too cold at night.
Yeah.
It was cold at night.
You need something over here.
So we'd lay something on the deck,
you know,
box or cardboard or extra blankets or something just to get off the thing.
And then you put a Poncho over and that would hold the heat to keep you warm,
but it wouldn't scholarly and no.
Yes.
And then what about the,
uh,
the,
razor burn razor grass?
I've heard about that.
Let me tell you.
When I heard about,
uh,
we heard about
the razor grass,
uh,
Mac Arthur decided he wanted to use paratroopers in the jungles of you Guinea.
And so they decided to send in a regimen,
I forget how many are sent in.
And they took pictures of reward the warm to the land in the jungles,
you know,
and they found this place at grassed in area and uh,
no trees in that part and so forth.
Ideal Place Lens.
So the jump in there and that was that and raise our glass 12 feet high.
And they had guys all cut up on it doing all the parachutes and grass was
terrible.
And,
uh,
two of them are killed in the Jumpman and a couple of them landed in the jungle,
you know,
on or hurt bad by then.
And then they told us two guys were never heard of or seen again.
They never didn't had to march out because it couldn't land a planning playing
in the jungles to take them out.
And it took them six weeks to get back to their base and they had to be,
uh,
you know,
fed along the way.
They,
that parachute stuff into them and so forth.
So that's when the Marine Corps that,
hey,
we're not using the fire tubes in the jungle.
So that's when they brought us back to the states and put this in
now,
uh,
how long was it after you guys landed that John Basilone was killed?
Well,
as well as I can remember,
I guess it's a first day because I was,
I had to go back,
get some tea and tea and,
and the guy was with me,
he had to get some napalm,
you know,
he's a flame thrower.
And,
uh,
and we saw this group of guys over there.
And,
and,
and a guy give him the last rites to someone.
What's going on here?
And this guy's head bashed alone.
This was just killed.
And
it was a sad moment for me because he,
like all the other marines,
he was a,
he wrote to us all,
you know,
and,
uh,
that was bad.
And then I heard that hall had been killed.
I cried again.
I cried.
And unashamedly,
you know,
because they,
they,
they meant a lot to me,
you know,
and,
uh,
I just found out we're hall was buried,
you know,
he didn't evidently didn't have a family.
I mean the wife or anything like that.
And I couldn't find out,
worry,
worry was,
you know,
where it had been buried or anything.
And this girl that found this thing for me,
she was,
her name was,
uh,
Liberty Phillips.
And I'd been trying for 20 years to find this guy,
you know,
and what happened to him and everything.
And I told her my problem.
And three days.
She had this magazine on the way she found out food,
computer,
you know what it was all about and hours amazed at that.
And then she found out that hauled it had been buried and uh,
well at first and he will,
they got so many dead that the hospital ships couldn't take them and so forth.
So they had to do something with a body.
So they begin to bury him there and they stayed there temporarily for several
years and brought them back to the states.
And,
uh,
he was buried and no one claimed it body.
And he was buried here in,
I mean in Hawaii at the punchbowl I thing rose and I'm going to go over some day
to visit his grave because possibility,
you know,
I've found a second cousin to Amy's uh,
he uh,
works with the Symphony Orchestra,
Orchestra and Cincinnati and he didn't,
uh,
he never met WRAL but he just heard his second cousin and he didn't know
anything about kin folks or anything to him,
you know,
as we progress through the,
the battle here,
um,
you wrote about it obviously here in the book and I think,
uh,
this,
this description here is
worth reading.
So I'm going to go,
you're out on patrol.
You're trying to get back to friendly lines,
daylights common.
And here we go.
I brought up the rear when we took off in a low moving dog trot cause lights
coming.
So you're,
you're trying to make some movement here.
Yeah,
we're not going far.
When from within five yards of my five o'clock position,
I heard the bolt action on a machine gun declaring the operator had embraced it
for firing.
I had heard this harbinger of death before.
It stood as one of the hard lessons I've learned in the jungles during the
Solomon Islands campaigns.
I recognized this telling sound of a Nambuu,
a Japanese light machine gun.
This deadly weapon could spit out a clip of 20 cartridges in less than two
heartbeats.
Damn,
I hated that nasty little 25 caliber weapon at that first metallic sound.
I shouted.
Hit the deck.
I landed on the ground at the same instant that assured short burst of gunfire
rip through the air just inches above my head.
I lay so flat on the deck that I could have crawled under a snakes belly for
Joe.
The guy in front of me,
luck and played out.
He had taken luck,
had played out.
He had taken one or more slugs in the back.
The other man ran helter skelter,
skelter toward our lines.
His head long dash grabbed the attention of the Nambuu and it continued to spit
short bursts at this hustling marine.
While this happened to the adrenaline and sense of reasoning within me worked in
tandem,
each feeding off each other.
My situation was critical.
I lay in the Japs backyard.
My position exposed with only my pistol to defend myself.
I took a quick peek at the inner body,
seven or eight yards ahead of me seeing no movement.
I reckon Joe had bought the farm.
He carried an m one rifle to survive this untenable fix.
I needed that rifle and a position of concealment.
I knew that the NAM booze clip held 20 cartridges and the gunner fired in short
bursts of three to four bullets.
I figured he had only a burst or two left.
He had one when the clip played out,
it ejected.
The sharp,
tinny sound singled me,
signaled me to move and move.
I did.
I came out of that prone position like a bolt of lightening man.
In that span of eight yards,
I could've beaten Jesse Owens.
My plan was simple.
I'd race by,
pick up,
pick up on a dead run and try and make it to the line of Boulder's about 20
yards beyond dam.
About a third,
about on about the third step,
I saw Joe move slightly.
The plan had changed.
I opted to take him instead.
When I got there,
I grabbed the back of his collar,
utter panic,
Poured Raj adrenaline into my engines.
I could never have dragged him that far fast.
Otherwise the rocks as a safe haven no longer stood as an option.
We couldn't make it that far out.
Out of gut wrenching terror.
I reacted on impulse,
not rooted in thought or reasoning with Joe.
Now,
until we moved into a slight depression in the volcanic ash.
No more than a shallow dip.
It had to do as duty.
It had to do duty as shelter for the time being,
what?
A poor place to defend,
and it offered very little in way of protection,
but nothing else showed any more promise by instinct.
I hit the deck,
my timing proved perfect.
The rattling peel of gunfire passed within inches of our heads.
Well,
I figured we were safe for the time being.
Then problems began to escalate faster than I could resolve them.
So this is a bad situation you're in right now,
man.
And then you look down and you see there's a thermite grenade that's,
that's that he's got on his gear that Joe has on his gear and it looks like it
has been shot or it's been hit with a glancing bullet.
And it looks like that thing could go off at any time as well.
Not only that,
you got the Nambuu being reloaded.
So from there you,
I think you stick Joe
with some,
some,
uh,
some morphine and you kind of hold station.
How long were you in that little depression in volcanic ash waiting?
Well,
they,
we estimated it was about a six and a half hours that we were in that,
yeah.
Deprivation and a volcanic ash.
And it was kind of a slope.
And then the depression and the
bullet hit that above us,
you know,
that was no way she could get,
and who is safe at that?
As long as we stayed down
and on top of all that,
you start receiving friendly fire for mortars,
mortars start going on.
Oh yeah,
they were,
I was just normal,
you know,
or they were throwing a lot of the martyr shalers in,
uh,
and,
and the ships were firing a heavy stuff but not rotted in that there where we
were.
And,
uh,
okay.
What do you think,
what prevented the Japanese from maneuvering on you?
Will you just holding that position to the best of your ability?
Throwing grenades and whatnot?
Yeah,
that's the only thing we could do it,
I couldn't move,
so I just had to,
yeah.
Hope.
But he didn't come.
And then when they gave out hope or why I was prepared,
I had a pistol.
I was gonna make sure that we didn't take,
we didn't take him prisoner,
you know,
because
at Velo Lavella we were on a patrol and a platoon of us.
And,
uh,
we met some jabs and,
one guy was hurt and we didn't know he was hurt and we failed back a little bit.
And then we realized that this guy,
his name was Joe shot,
my fucking thank for his last name now,
and the Jap should captured him.
And we dug in for the night.
And,
uh,
they begin to target your ham
and,
uh,
and he would,
you know,
screaming and everything and our officers that don't move,
don't move.
We can't help him.
I'm just trying to get you in position,
don't move,
don't move and everything.
We sit there and listen to him and into the night and then the morning when it
got lunch,
you know,
we went and after him and he was tied to the base of a tree with his penis cut
off and then was in his mouth and it taking scripture of the scan and pulled it
off that long and just really tortured,
deem something terrible.
And uh,
we were not,
we found out that they were
Royal Manchurian marines,
you know,
Japanese had in Manchuria had a colony up there and they were bigger than a
regular Japanese.
They might've been Chinese and uh,
but,
uh,
they were big guys and uh,
and we got,
got back at him,
everyone about 10 of them,
I guess in that group.
And we finally caught up with them.
But that poor guy suffered.
And it was hard not to jump up and go,
but that's what they want us to do,
you know,
to come out of the household.
Because once we got there in a foxhole at night,
we were not forced to move for any reason.
If you had to use the toilet where you use dug a hole in your hole and uh,
an old holes and the John with water would seep in,
I'm overnight and you're constantly
a Tin Cup to take water out,
throw it out button.
And the Joan builders,
it was terrible.
Really terrible in all the conditions were bad.
Uh,
the mosquitoes were bad,
just jungle robot and I hated that and he didn't get that at the gym or you
know,
I don't remember seeing a mosquito or having a mosquito bite then,
uh,
w Jima.
Okay.
And with that and your mind,
there's no way that you were going to get captured,
you or
governor be captured?
I Wa I was ready to.
Okay.
Uh,
take Joe out myself because I didn't want him to suffer like that either.
Yeah.
Or started.
I didn't tell him I was going to shoot him,
but uh,
I was ready to do it.
You spend the whole day there and I'm going back to the book.
As the long lonely hours ticked away,
thoughts root ran the gauntlet of my mind.
Early in the weight I resolved to go down fighting.
I considered surrender out of the question and never an option.
I had heard and seen the results of the enemy's treatment of prisoners.
No words can describe the pain and suffering the jabs laid on a person before
permitting him to die.
While the political correctness these days might frown on calling them Jabs,
I'll call them anything.
I please my buddies and I have that right.
We have earned it.
Yes.
When a show down came,
I intended to see that the enemy didn't take me or the marine lying next to me
alive as my longest day.
Near the halfway point through the dean of battle,
I heard my name called damn the voice of Bull Fisher.
My platoon sergeant boomed over the other noise he had brought in a combat
patrol to find us.
Now you,
you kind of link up and he's trying to figure out where the Nam Bo is Nambuu is
located.
We see you now throw I did in the Nambuu answered,
giving away its position.
A platoon laid down a withering barrage of small arms fire,
putting the Nam boot company out of business.
Peter.
Adam got to be first along with several other guys.
He directed them to put Joe on the stretcher and sent them on their way.
He said he,
he said,
let's get you out of here.
I'll cover you.
I got set to make a run for it,
but as an afterthought,
I told Pete that I wanted to pick up Joe's rifle.
I took one last look at the shallow deaf laid in the sands of Ego Jima.
What a life saver,
the dearest plot of ground that I ever occupied.
Joe and I owed our lives to it in a state of rage.
Pete said we would have found you sooner,
but ski came back a blithering idiot.
You refuse to go back to show us the way to you guys.
He reported you dead.
Some of the guys wanted to shoot him.
The bowl sent him under guard to be taken off the island.
Okay.
And now I'm going to a
read a an award citation.
The president of United States takes pleasure in presenting the silver star
medal to private first class deal f Harvey Jr United States Marine Corps for
services set forth in this following citation for conspicuous gallantry and
[inaudible] while serving with company c First Battalion 26 marines,
Fifth Marine Division in action against enemy Japanese forces on Eog mud volcano
islands 20 February,
1945 when he's three man patrol,
which was sent out to establish contact with the adjoining company,
was ambushed by heavy fire from an enemy machine gun and one of the men were
seriously wounded.
Private FirstClass Harvey drag the fallen marine under heavy fire to the shelter
of a nearby whole remaining with the wounded man.
While his companion went for aid,
he held off the hostile forces with his rifle in hand grenades until the arrival
of the rescue party then exposing himself to enemy fire and directing accurate
heavy fire on the Japanese position.
He successfully covered the evacuation of the casualty by his initiative,
courage and unselfish devotion to duty.
He undoubtedly saved the life of his comrade and upheld the highest traditions
of United States naval service for the president,
John Sullivan.
Okay.
Secretary of the navy.
Don't really know what to say after reading that,
sir.
Oh,
well that was a long day for me,
but uh,
I didn't think,
oh
they the reward.
I was just doing what the Marines are taught to do.
No,
and uh,
I was surprised when they pinned a oh man.
Yeah.
You talked a little bit earlier about what it was like at night and I thought
this was a really good section
of the book.
Here's the way we handled the nights on the front line.
Once darkness set in,
everyone went to his foxhole,
orders,
said no one left the hole for any reason.
As I pointed out,
we seated the night to the enemy from caves and tunnels within our lines in
units,
these adversaries info infiltrated our positions.
They sought to come into our holes and kill with knives.
Bayonets,
bayonets are guns.
Some simply moved in close enough to toss in a hand grenade if they found the
occupants on the alert for them.
So we declared open season on anyone moving around above ground
to combat this type of warfare.
Each foxhole comprised more or less a mini fortress within itself.
The man on watch with weapon ready sat near the top of the hole.
So we had a panoramic view of his surroundings.
This proved vital as the deadly nocturnal infiltrators came in from all
directions while on watch,
you had to stay mentally alert,
clear headed and responsive to any movement near your position.
Uh,
moving shadow in the night presented a target to challenge with gunfire.
I had the first two hour watch when tired,
sleepy,
hungry,
scared,
lonesome and hones sit homesick.
A two hour watch seems like an eternity.
The constant booming of incoming and outgoing cannon blast filled the night air
intermingled with the ear splitting blast came the prevailing rattle of machine
gun and rifle fire interwoven with the Blair and the clamor of these machines of
war.
You heard desperate or human utterances filled with all the emotions that life
allows when you're watching ends.
The night calls on you to sleep.
Sheer debilitating exhaustion will put you to sleep usually a restless,
troubled slumber.
I'm going to continue on in the deep of the night after my second round of
sentinel duty,
a Staccato of pistol fire at point blank range startled me awake.
I leaped to my feet at full alert.
I could see Masseria crouched up beyond the dividing Ridge in a horse whisperer.
I asked what's up?
He answered,
we have a visitor.
Did you get him?
I don't think so.
Where on your side then?
I heard it.
The dreaded sound of metal striking the wooden stock of a rifle.
A Japanese grenade activates by whacking it's firing pin against a solid object.
This whack ignites a fuse that Burns for seven seconds before detonation.
Beyond the rim of my whole hidden in the darkness and enemy soldier had the drop
on me.
I had no options or defense for the inevitable.
Then I saw it coming in a looping arc toward me,
a harbinger of death.
The burning fuse gave off a radiant sparkling light like a kid sparkler on the
4th of July.
I had to get it out of a hole before it exploded with a sense of urgency
enhanced by stark terror.
I copped both hands together.
I caught it in mid air and shoveled it over the rim of the hole out of harm's
way.
Sadly,
the rapid,
rapidly burning fuse did not give me time to scoop the missile back in the
direction from whence it came.
Masiya had my pistol else.
I could have scrambled to the top of the hole and possibly got some shots off at
the adversary,
but I could only crouch and weight.
Okay.
The interval didn't last long as out of the darkness came a notifying sound
telling us they had armed another grenade and send it on its way.
However,
this granite dear showed some smarts.
He held the grenade for about two seconds before tossing it.
This delay gave me only five seconds to do my thing out of anxiety.
I reacted too quickly and bobbled it.
As I hit the deck,
I kicked it at the same time throwing up my arms instinctively to protect my
chest and head the kick and the explosion occurred simultaneously.
My feet and legs took most of the shrapnel and volcanic ash hatched by the
blast.
I fell to my butt to a sitting position on the slanting side of the hole.
I felt very little pain in my lower limbs,
but my head throbbed with the mother of all headaches.
I had a deafening ringing in my ears accompanied by excruciating pain.
I couldn't feel her move my legs.
I sat there stunned deaf and trying to recollect my notions.
Another grenade landed within inches beside me.
Without thought or reason,
I hoisted my hips to come down on the glittering missile.
This witless act placed the right cheek of my buttocks on the device.
My weight pushed the grenade into loose volcanic ash,
which are absorbed a great deal of the energy generated by the blast.
Okay.
Now this one really laid some heard on me.
I knew that I had to get some help quick like,
or I might leave that paid alive help.
I realized sat about 25 yards away.
I couldn't stand or even feel my legs.
So walking or even crawling exceeded my ex,
my options,
dragging myself with my elbows and hands appeared my only option getting to the
top and out of a hole took just about all my strength,
kind of like swimming upstream in the waters of a flood of a river at flood
stage,
at the top of the hole,
I lost it.
I either fainted or out of futility,
a seated to death.
I know not which lying there and that state of oblivion.
And if the euro entity began to take form in my mind's vision,
out of this ghostly apparition,
I came face to face with the voice of my mother.
She commanded sunny.
You wake up and get to those who can help you.
Don't you dare give up.
We all love you and need and you need to return to us.
Okay.
And then my former football coach,
Joe Coleman appeared
and he said,
Harvey,
you sorry,
Little Shit.
Get off.
You're dead ass and move out.
There's hell to pay and you got to pay it.
I ain't,
I ain't and none of your quitting.
Now Hustle,
Alice.
I'm kicking your skinny.
But
when the old coach spoke,
it came out as demanding commands.
You listened and you reacted.
You know,
I reached deep inside myself and find the strength and power to drag my failing
body the last few yards to help and safety.
Yeah.
Thanks coach Joe
at the brink of the whole,
I came to a halt to alert those inside of my presence before exposing myself to
possible friendly fire.
I called out Sam.
This is Harvey and I'm hurt bad.
I'm coming in now.
Don't shoot.
So
three grenades thrown at you in your whole fear saved me.
You were able to throw the first one back.
Well,
just kind of shoved it back out.
That actually catch it out of this shell.
Read it out.
Just struck my hand and I got it out of the whole completely,
but not where our shooter a warranted it.
Go back toward the guy that the donut,
but that didn't happen.
And then the second one,
you Bob,
a little,
a little bit.
Lands at your feet.
Yes,
it landed at my feet.
I kicked it,
kicked,
took me out of the game.
How many days?
This was six or seven days into the battle of this happened the ninth,
the night.
Okay.
Everyone's the same.
That my buddy the dark,
whereas we're going to do and so forth.
And you were going to tell that story about how he got wounded?
Yeah.
Which is,
I mean it's in the book.
It's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
You want to tell us how he would,
how he explained that situation to you?
Yeah.
I'll tell you.
Hey,
he was a good marine.
I mean,
when the chips were down,
he played the game.
He was put out front.
Uh,
uh,
he was a scout sniper.
That was his designation.
And they had in the whole [inaudible],
uh,
a young guy that never been in action for Dan.
It cruel.
And then it was a,
okay,
uh,
B a r man,
brr to Browning automatic rifle.
So they're in the whole carvers and there's Poncho getting arrest.
And then they were supposed to be on watch.
Well,
uh,
carburetors were sound asleep and they were awakened by a gash.
Cry Out in know and he rolls the Poncho Edge,
real slow light look.
And you saw that the jab straddled a den it crew and it cut his throat
or copperhead is k bar nine
brought Darba beside him stuck in the thing.
So it took the math and was able to get the job and in the end the back and took
him out of the picture.
But there were two other jobs in the home.
They didn't know that carver was under that Poncho and he didn't know that there
was in the,
oh sorry.
Yeah,
you got to his knees,
it turned and there was a jail begin to ban it.
Name show where they got him in the chest.
Got One long,
they've got them in shifts three times and he had his arms up,
fruit protect himself.
And One jab stuck is,
is a band through his forearm here.
Came out here,
went through the muscle here.
Out here.
Okay.
And the other jobs,
but the same hurt on this on his left side.
So here he is.
Lexan is mushroom lake.
Kate dry get,
uh,
they're abandoned.
It's out.
Of course when they flex the muscle that tied them up.
And so he's struggling there.
Well a guy back up on side of the hill,
he saw this action figure that copper and then the girl that had it.
So he told us a hand grenade down there and it didn't go in the hole,
but it must have done some damage to the uh,
uh,
guys that,
the ban in Japanese,
you know.
Okay.
Well the Japanese are scared off.
So they left
scrambled out of the hole and carver was able to get his arms divorced from the
ban it and it was,
took Danny accruals,
B a r n shot overs to jobs as he ran down the hill
and he was awarded a Silver Star for that.
He deserved it.
Well,
is there told you before,
carver loved his beer when he hit dial in,
he had 14 cans of beer alone that that ninth not left.
Okay.
On the ninth night when both of us were hurt,
he had only eight cans of beer left.
Well,
they finally get to Carber and get him on a stretcher.
And there's Karen and back now this is dark or the night
and they gave him on a stretcher and takes him to the rear for help and
everything.
And he's having trouble cause bloat is farming in his mouth,
his nose and so forth,
but is able to tell the guys,
I forget to sergeant,
where's Karen named Rod?
Uh,
but he said,
when you guys get back,
there's beer in my
backpack.
Plop a dropping.
They run back there.
You got the beer and drank it.
And while they're still in the hole,
come back.
I can't find dark.
It's dark.
And he's calling out to him and he can't be heard because he had so much blood
in his mouth and everything.
Right.
So he laid there until dawn until it got loud enough to find it.
Well,
he loves to tell his story when he gets around a bunch of guys at the Uso and
the American Legion and Veterans of Foreign Wars,
and I'll take them over those from the hospital.
I'll take him over and he tells that story.
So this is my buddy.
He needed to got me killed.
They're not telling the true story,
you know,
he nearly got himself killed.
He was a character.
And although that guy,
he was really a guy.
And I guess the lesson to be learned there is marines love their beer.
Oh yeah.
I love their beer.
Now you get,
and you already seen the flag be rate been raised?
Well,
uh,
I think I were raised about the third day there.
I guess it was somewhere like that,
but I was on the far side of the island on the other beach.
I think I'd,
uh,
alluded to that earlier tonight.
Well,
anyway,
uh,
let's see how that was happening.
Oh,
I was working,
it was a big cliff there.
And uh,
and there was a,
a field box on the side of that other beats.
You know,
we ran to the beach over there,
whether there's a pillbox boxer and it was,
they had a,
uh,
[inaudible] I guess was firing that those ships are sitting out there.
There are small boats and everything.
Well,
we're sitting up there and uh,
and this pill boxes on the side of this slope and healed down to the s down to
the beach,
you know,
and uh,
so they loaded me on a rope to put a shape charge on the top of that.
A pillbox,
you know,
is concrete.
So the Dourdan me down or not put a shape charge on that and that didn't phase
that the stuff.
So the pulled pulled me back up and then a guy was with us radio that uh,
uh,
oh that little ship out there,
let's see as a,
uh,
landing craft emptor Lci.
And they had a twin barrel,
a 40 millimeter Mo,
uh,
deal up there.
And they began to firing the right time and they just pumping thing.
They were bringing in these clips with,
for those sales on it,
putting them up by,
and this guy would firing.
And another guy had pulled him off our need to get through it and they laugh.
And then we've been up and they finally just drilled a hole in that thing that a
pillbox just exploded.
We use a power chair and every cheer and one of the things is,
and later on that day,
uh,
we'd come up to a cliff,
a healed thing and a really big door over a cave,
uh,
on the side of that cliff.
And it was heavy with wood and metal,
so forth.
So I had to use,
I was going to use a TNT blasted in,
so I put the t and t,
uh,
but,
the whole pack on the polls and I was carrying it and I was going to come up the
side there and the guys were protecting me,
you know,
around in the end he Jepser came out to meet me or anything.
So I'm slipping up or,
and I have my pistol that my mom had sent me.
I had that Mariah at hand and I had this,
uh,
charge of t and t own on a pole and I was slipping up on that thing from that,
from the side.
And I was going to put that down there and put a short fuse on it and blow it
out.
Well as I was walking up,
or
a jump come runner from around a rock rock darling at abandoned come charging
that and that took a pistol and shot him about three times in the belly.
And that's the only time I'd ever knew that I'd killed.
That was my kill right there.
Nobody fired.
Cause other times when we'd see a job,
there may be four or five of us firing at the same time,
you know,
so he couldn't click.
But that was my key.
They all cheered me back over here.
And,
uh,
so I sent off that t and t and it didn't phase that a door at all.
And so,
uh,
as I,
as coming back and we were looking at,
uh,
that guy's rifles and he was now the bullets,
the one that doesn't songs,
you know,
and so about that time heard a cheer,
men a charity,
there's like somebody who made a touchdown,
you know,
and,
and a step back and look,
a burner.
That flag just been raised.
And I was about
all about 50 yards,
I guess from a base of that,
uh,
volcanic volcano of that.
Sarah bace.
And a,
and I thought,
man,
the war's over.
I'd say we have one,
but it went on for for another 30,
30 days,
you know.
But,
uh,
our Hayes,
was one of the guys lifted that thing and I knew him and uh,
of course,
Yep.
One
time I thought I was the only guy on the island that didn't help raise that flag
because everybody was sitting.
I was one of those guys that raises the flag.
Eh.
And that was one of the last things you saw as you,
before you got evacuated out.
I know you,
you talk about in the book you had him turn your a stretcher so you could see
the flag before you left medically evacuated.
Yeah.
Well,
I always hurt lead arts and I were both hearts the same night,
uh,
the night night,
but there were some,
uh,
discussion about,
we were hurt the third night or something.
Was it third now?
That's just poor reporting.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
uh,
he was hurt.
Same that I was and,
and uh,
uh,
I was taking the out to,
put on,
well,
I wound up in a long ditch that did just use the bulldozer and uh,
in the volcano cast,
just dug a hole there and it was about a hundred yards alone and it was just
lined with guys on the stretcher and you guys are working on.
And uh,
I woke up and
I had been doped up,
you know,
and I walked up and I knew somebody who was working over me and,
uh,
it got to my boots and I wanted my boots.
I was proud of those boots,
paratrooper boots,
you know,
and he said,
aw,
one of them is no good.
And then I said,
I want to make him be fixed.
And I was nearly in tears,
you know,
because I was hurt and that is under the influence of morphine and stuff like
that.
So I said,
I know I want my boots,
I won't my boots.
And so he took them off and I was laying on my stomach hug.
Those boots are right here.
Pull them up to me because I wasn't going to lose my boots are so proud of.
And then,
uh,
I went out and the next thing I know I'm being put on the,
a board.
I was in the eldest,
uh,
a below an lst and they were going to take me off that board with,
for the guys with a platform on cables and you're going to pull it.
They started pulling up and one of those
stretchers fell off.
It was metal,
uh,
farmed and uh,
chicken wire on the bottom of it because it was a metal stretcher and that went
to the bank and it was about 12 sailors on that,
on the Higgins boat and on the lst men.
They dove in there trying to get to that guy,
but he just went down so fast and it was when he wasn't able to save him.
And so they pulled me around to the front of the rest of us around.
There's about
four or five of us still on,
on those,
sort of pulled us around and they open,
those doors are on the lst and that the ramp down,
that bolt just went up.
The Higgins boat just went up on the tech itself.
It took us up on the top deck,
pulling alongside the USS Ozark.
Now that's a mountain.
So the uh,
uh,
supply ships,
and troop trench,
uh,
ports.
We're named after mountains.
So the ls,
uh,
the USS,
Ozark us where I was taken up there and I was on the deck.
It was raining and uh,
and a doctor was going through and picking them out and he got to me and said,
he said,
take this guy and first take him right on the end.
And I said,
I wanted to see the flag.
He said,
well,
he's upfront router.
And just like a miracle at ship slid around on anchor because the season was
really rough that day and it rain and everything,
but all of a sudden there's a shafts of light and come and light coming through
the clouds.
And you could see that flag up.
And I cried and then they took me down there and I still had my boots.
And the doctor,
Dr. Anderson,
uh,
he said,
take him on in Iraq quick.
But uh,
and so went in and they put me up on a table and I still hadn't my boots and a
corpsman tried to take my boots and I wouldn't get dull.
You don't take my boots,
you're not,
don't take my boot.
And Dr. Anderson said,
let him keep his boots.
Well,
the next thing I know,
I'm in a,
in a room about this big,
and it's in the room where the ship's crew,
Leo,
that's had their bunks in there.
So I'm on a bunk.
It's about four or five feet high a here and then another bunk below.
But up there above,
I could reach those pipes going through there.
Uh,
two of the book held up here.
So a reach up there and now I'm under an influence of something that should
never have been given to me.
It wound up,
it was,
I was allergic to it,
so I know what I'm doing,
but I can't keep from doing it.
So I grabbed that pipe and pull myself off the bunk and I was going to hand over
hand to my boots.
I was going for my boots,
I was desperate,
you know,
I was crying out and it was calling from a boots.
The other thing I look back on,
I thought I was crazy as it should have been crazy or something.
Well,
anyway,
I get to a door
and above that door,
the pipes went through the,
the bulkhead up there.
And so I reached up and an hour is going to the other's room and a lost,
it all fell on the deck.
And uh,
and I don't know what happened,
but there was on the deck,
but a wound up in the big room.
Yeah.
He was a big area on this ship and it was lit up and there was all kinds of cots
all around here.
And you guys laying on it.
And they were the thing,
a lot of wake up and I'm thirsty.
I've got to use,
uh,
I've got,
do other bowel movement.
And I was real men,
so hollered real loud.
Korman there's no Korman and I didn't have any needles in me,
you know,
uh,
feeding me,
you know,
uh,
all that stuff.
And so I hollered and all of these guys,
he had head wounds and bandages on their head,
you know,
and they all hollered everything and we've got what's going on.
So laid there and there was a guy next to me and of course he has hit his
hearing.
My head's over here and I could see he was looking up at the ceiling.
I said,
hey mate,
we're the Corman's here.
And he didn't answer me.
And I got real mad about him.
I said,
let me know what's going on here.
So a hall,
a real loud again and all these guys begin holler and scream and everything.
And,
and I was shaking my head and mad and everything hungry and,
and it's miserable.
And so I gave up and uh,
and I laid there for a wall leader.
Well,
the heard the door open and I looked up it over,
hears about 30 yards,
I guess for me and this big room.
Well,
there was a truck or or something over there,
park,
and they use those called tanks,
trucks and things that are shipped or tie.
But this room was well lit and all these guys with this laying on a cots,
you know,
when I heard the door slam
and I look up and it's Dr. Anderson got it.
That operated on me.
So a hauler real loud,
Dr. Anderson and all of these guys begin to Holler and scream at me and
everything.
And he walked on down there and he just kind of shook his head and kept walking,
you know,
and uh,
and then man,
I knew I was in trouble and needed help,
you know,
I said,
I'm going to watch that door if he comes through again.
And when he walked in and went out the door on the left side,
so I waited and sure enough,
about 30 minutes or something like that,
I don't,
I have,
I heard this door open and he was,
Dr. Anderson comes in,
so I'm smart.
I'm not going to Holler that these other guys fade me out.
So I began waving,
I begin to waven.
He's the walking,
kept walking up there.
Then I said,
I had to Holler.
So Ha,
uh,
hollered again,
Dr. Anderson and uh,
all these guys begin to Holler.
And then he stopped and kind of shook his head and I was waving at this time.
And so he comes over there.
He said,
what Harvey,
what are you doing down here?
I said,
I don't know.
He said,
I've been looking two days for you and I just presumed you'd been buried at sea.
And uh,
he said,
you don't know how you got down here?
And I said,
no,
I don't know how I got down here.
So he said,
I'll go get help.
They don't go anywhere.
And I said,
I'm not going.
Oh wait for him.
While I was waiting for him,
there was a group of about 12 guys came in
and I could tell they were doctors in corpsman did everything.
And they started over here and they come to a thing,
God,
it'd be two guys had put,
they had stem scopes on it,
put on these guys that were laying there.
And sometimes they'd just shake their head.
And it was Corbyn would take them off and put him on a,
a,
uh,
a stretcher and take him away.
And he's working longer and God is hoping to,
Dr. Anderson would get back and these guys would come to one Yadda Raton and
they'd shake him off leaving [inaudible] and going around.
So,
uh,
Dr. Anderson came back down there.
Well,
these guys going,
I said,
doctor,
what are these guys do?
And they,
some of these guys out,
he said,
Harvey,
okay,
these guys,
we,
there's nothing we can do to happen.
They have head injuries,
brain injuries,
and they're brain dead right now.
You said there's no hope for him.
We can't do anything for them.
So we're bearing most of them.
But see,
and I said,
uh,
I said,
what was I doing down here?
And he said,
I don't know how in the world that got you down here.
And I told him what I'd done,
you know,
and they didn't know what to do with me,
so they just put me down there with those guys.
And so he said,
you wait here.
And I said,
I'll wait here.
So you went up and came back with four Korman the with them and they put me on
the,
on the stretcher and took me over to the door and a doctor,
he got done on a drop down on one knee and these guys were working together.
I said,
doctor,
yeah,
you can't help.
These guys are saying no,
we can't help them.
There's nothing we can do there in God's hand.
And I said,
well I guess I was in God's hand to for awhile.
He should.
Yeah,
I guess so.
So said we're going to poorly into Guam,
we would be taking you off,
you'll be taking back to Hawaii and so forth.
And so sure enough,
about an hour they took me off,
she up,
Dr. Anderson came down and,
and thanked him.
I guess he saved my life
and then they took me I the heights,
the Pearl Harbor and that's where I was.
I was in a full body,
cashed up to here all the way down.
Dad Split each leg,
had a cast over it to all one piece.
And uh,
they put me in a room with this guy here.
Now
when you,
before we talk about that,
I know you brought up a photograph today,
a big photograph of um,
uh,
you know,
very kind of typical,
a picture that you see of a,
of a bunch of military guys.
And this is a picture of,
of marines clearly.
And this picture right here is a picture of the first
it in seat company 26 marines invasion.
And these are,
this is your,
in this photograph.
This is,
this is your company that you went into [inaudible] how many people are in this
picture?
to a,
at the end of the Bible.
After 36 days,
I think 14 of these guys walked off the island,
rest of them were wounded,
carried off or died.
A lot of them were buried at sea because they had six hospitals,
ships and they filled up real fast and they had to go to Guam and SAP pan to be
taken off.
Flown back to Hawaii.
243 started in 14.
Walked off the island.
Yeah.
Uh,
unbelievable.
And I've had this picture for years and one of them hanging in east to hang out
with my bed.
Never.
Not that I would look at these guys,
you know,
and then I moved into my living room right there and watch it.
I'd looked at it every day cause I don't want to forget these guys.
I,
I won't forget and,
and I can remember their faces,
but it's hard for me to still put names to a lot of them.
I like darts.
I remember him,
Peter,
Adam member,
him,
uh,
officers,
I remember him and uh,
and just 14 guys walked off that island and,
or really costly in lives and everything.
And I'm not going to ever forget these guys.
We won't either,
sir.
Yeah.
Which when you're in Guam now you're,
you're basically in a medical ward,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I ate a highest was the name of the hospital.
It overlooks Pearl Harbor.
It was built there after the war started,
you know,
and so I'm in this,
uh,
and you get reunited with,
with a copper at this point,
right?
Yeah.
You guys couldn't get away from each other.
Let me digress here.
I was put into a room in that hospital,
I,
the heights and Hawaii.
I was put in this room with another bed and a guy in that bed and he had a head
bandage
over him and I was laying next to him and I couldn't see him and he wouldn't
talk to me and everything.
So I didn't say anything to them and everything.
And uh,
and the had come in there and they'd take him off bringing it back out to a
wall.
And,
and he never talked to,
never say anything.
I gave up trying to talk to him and so forth
while I'm laying there feeling sorry for myself.
And,
uh,
I hear somebody,
Fred Harvey,
are you in this war?
Just loud,
you know,
not a recognized carvers voice.
He has a Washer to carry for a mom.
Everything.
So I'm raised up,
I'm in this room is about this big here,
you know,
I'm in the bed here and this other guys in the bid over here and I raise up
enough and I could see cover down there and he's hollering,
kept Paul and Fred or this little nurse ran down there and got in his face and
he said,
you just keep your mouth shut down to,
I mean,
she really read him off.
Well I'm looking for my buddy.
They said he,
he said,
she said he's in this ward but he's in the room on the end on here.
And so she pointed,
laid him down there and he came in there and everyone was covered.
Man,
now he's in
it,
bandaged up like this,
you know,
his arms and everything,
you know that taking over band nets and he is pushing bill Krause who's in a
wheelchair
with one of his legs missing.
And carbon was pushing him like this.
And,
and uh,
Bill was sitting,
I directed him and everything,
so
cover their standing in the door and he said,
what are they?
He got was Harvey and this guy standing here in this little room by themselves,
they said,
well,
because of the injuries,
you know,
on everything,
why aren't out here with the other marines?
What?
She went over and closed the door,
but she didn't close it all.
I could hear him talk.
He said,
well,
you buddy over here,
we don't know what to do with him.
He got injuries and uh,
his legs are blood clotted and so forth.
So we don't know what to do for him.
And,
uh,
and this guy over here,
he's,
he's lost his face.
He can't communicate.
He wants to die.
And Gosh,
I kind of scared me,
you know,
and everything.
So carver said,
put 'em out of here with the other marines.
Right.
Uh,
and um,
so we went up burn and the nurses area,
Roger Hears about halfway down the hall,
that Hall Ward,
most of them 70 yards long anyway,
and vegetate on each side and nurses right here in the middle.
Well,
they put me over here and put,
uh,
this go here on the right side.
And uh,
governor said we'll take those bandages it off of his face and nurses.
Well,
he doesn't want them taken,
although I should take them off right there.
People got,
have to see him.
He's going to have to live with it.
And so a large scene it when they a doctor,
do you mean when I looked over there,
this was all gone.
You could see the back of his neck,
back diaries,
backbone and everything on it,
dying on his face versus his eyes.
And he had his ear and uh,
and I'm way they can feed him,
you know,
nobody,
he could eat anything and they just fed him like we were feeding me too,
you know,
just intravenously right there.
And they put them over and that Guy Cabo would talk to him,
you know,
he said,
Tai Chi bandages off,
you're going to have to live with that.
[inaudible] you're with marines and we all understand and lug it and everything.
And so he took off the bandage and left them off.
All of these marines come by and glance at him and then patty,
me and on and so forth.
And he
a spiritual rose,
you know,
and of course she couldn't tell us that,
but you could tell about his actions and everything.
So Macabre.
Uh,
this is uh,
uh,
plastic surgery award we're on.
And the guy that headed up was named,
I can't think of his name right now,
but it was an all American football player and Wisconsin and had a big massive
guy with big hands and broad shoulders.
He was doing delicate operations on,
uh,
on guys,
you know,
plastic surgery.
And so,
uh,
they did,
they didn't know what to do with me because a blood clot,
they couldn't start operating on maybe because both of her legs had blood clots
all up in my stomach and so forth.
Carver told me later that,
uh,
that nurse had told him that there was way to not do them through it and not
been in our about a week.
And uh,
and cobber talk to this doctor,
what was his name?
He was an all American football player.
Well anyway,
he said,
is,
uh,
how are you going to fix it?
He said,
well,
we just gonna have to build him a new face,
but we can't start on him until he gets strong enough to take it,
you know,
and so forth.
And,
uh,
and so commerce said,
well,
the house something that,
things that she said,
yeah,
we got a little booklet over here that has six facial features on it.
[inaudible]
said,
let me see it.
So you'd look at six pages with
six facial features on it.
So carver gave it to Harold here and he took him to each bed and it had a note
on our written pick out the best looking face in this,
in this book,
but something,
oh voted on which face he wanted to know.
And this guy,
you know,
he was,
of course,
he was happy to be out with the other guys and everything and he would stay in
the wheelchair lot and go from place to place.
Guys would come over and talk to him and if he had anything to say,
you know,
he'd ride it out and so forth.
And,
uh,
then they,
started operating on him and they didn't know what to do with me.
I'm still laying there,
my cash.
And then one day the little nurse came up,
she's from Austin,
Texas is not king,
or he called her name rotten down,
but she was 65 years old at that time.
And they were trying to discharge her and she wouldn't let them discharge.
She said,
I'm going to stay in here until this war is completely over.
And she did
well,
she came home and told me,
we think we might have found a way to help you.
And she told me,
he said,
there's a guy as the,
uh,
item in the New England
medical journal or something like that.
And he,
he was in,
uh,
New Orleans and his name was Faust,
not member of the word south,
because there's an opera or written about Dr Files,
you know,
so I've remembered that name all alone.
And so,
uh,
she told the,
the commander of that hospital,
you know,
that she wanted that,
yeah.
To come over and look at me.
So they put him on a plane,
flew him over there,
and they look at me,
he says,
well,
we can't do anything until we operated on him.
And he said,
I have a way,
I think I might be able to help you.
When they came in there and they took a machine,
a vibrator or something and cut the top of that cast off of me and set it aside.
And then they put me on a table on my stomach
and,
and doctor [inaudible] puts six needles along my spine.
And,
uh,
you know what a football or basketball needle looks like needle about that long
and a little head on it,
you know,
screw into a pump.
Well,
anyway,
that's the way that there was things looked,
you know,
there's needles and built like that.
They weren't,
weren't the real thing,
but that's what lear,
well,
they stuck her nose along my spine and then he put some kind of fluid in there
and I thought they'd put gasoline on me and sent me a fire.
Yada did burned out.
I thought I was on fire that hey,
I thought they started killing it really.
And they said,
no,
that's just a symptom.
They're not burning up their thing.
And,
and so they gave me about six of those
treatments and the legs begin to clear up,
uh,
dissolved in the,
blood clots.
And then the doctor started operating on,
on me and plastic surgery.
And,
uh,
they,
a took skin off my legs and put it on my,
on my butt and everything.
And,
and then they took a picture of me and it looked like
my legs and my buttocks.
It had been worked over by a
dye that,
uh,
made tattoos on.
Guys looked like if a doctor had a tattoo,
artists had fouled up.
And this thing,
my whole back side was just black and it was that volcanic ash.
And,
uh,
so,
they got me,
got me up and got me fixed.
My legs begin to throw out,
you know,
the thing and,
uh,
it's going to take me,
they came in and asked me where I wanted to be taken to the hospital and the
closest one to my hometown,
where's Carpus Christian?
That was nearly 900 miles.
And so this doctor said,
hey,
uh,
Harvey,
how about coming to New Orleans?
We have a hospital there,
naval hospital there and I can look after your mower.
And I said,
well that's great.
So I was in and the harsh sent down there and carver had been sent before he had
left and gone to the east coast.
And so they uh,
they put me on a plane and flew me to California.
Well that blame was at constellation and I was told it was used for was in
hospital thing and we got nearly halfway home and the plane,
well problems.
And so here I am with a bunch of other guys that were all thrown into,
one was on a stretcher and so the nurse came in there and put things around me
and,
and gave instructions and all of these other guys would wait because I was
expecting that plane to go down.
And so they decided that it was one to the point of no return.
So the turnaround took us back to Honolulu.
All the hula girls medicine I thought were doing,
coming in raw vacation.
They put on a show for us and then they fixed the plane and finally got me over
to,
oh,
what's that town across the bay.
Dale.
A football team.
Learn a San Francisco.
What is the name of that?
Alameda.
Yeah.
And that's where the landed may rot.
And they put me out on the tarmac and I had my hands over my eyes like that.
The Sun was shining it
and somebody kicked me.
She said,
you little bastard,
the word and the hail,
that big van to cover the Scarborough.
Well he had been taken to another hospital further down the coast about 20,
30 miles from there.
And he had been hitchhiking the last three week hitchhiking over ever day to
meet and these planes that were bringing guys in.
And they finally found me.
And so
they took me over there and uh,
I can bring up the name of that hospital.
He was in
a side important.
So they,
uh,
doctor wanted,
admitted,
brought,
they brought back to New Orleans.
Well cobber we're still lowered in California.
When I lay out,
well,
I was,
uh,
I got in pretty good shape.
You know,
I walk around with a cane and crutches at time and,
and,
uh,
I heard that the air was a farm out outside of,
over across the river in,
uh,
in Algiers,
Louisiana.
And the Navy had an ammunition dump over there on the river across the river.
And,
uh,
and they lit marines go over there and Rehab,
Rehab,
uh,
you know,
get better.
And they didn't take care of things on the farm.
And so I heard about it and I begged him to let me go over there.
So they let me go over there and with his stipulation that I would take care of
chickens because it didn't take care of anything else.
And so here I went over and I was taking care of chickens and they had these
white Legere and chip chickens and the great facilities form live on.
They never got on the ground,
his own wire,
uh,
chicken wire,
you know,
and uh,
they had,
uh,
oats or something are planted,
the seeds thrown in there and these chickens or walk around.
And eat that green is called Ohana.
Well I would together up the eggs and take a man and uh,
doing that,
you know,
well the guy that was taken care of,
they got real mad cause that was a cushy job,
but as the only job I could do,
you know,
and so I was taking care of the chickens,
and feeling sorry for myself and,
and everything.
And I had a bucket full of eggs and uh,
I'd take him over there and they'd take them up the naval base,
uh,
eating place,
you know,
and uh,
he took care of all the eggs and so forth.
Well,
anyway,
I was out there,
I had a bunch of that and I had a walking on my using the cane and,
and I heard the horn are out there and guys screaming and I look up and,
and his lead darts,
he sitting up on the Kava the truck and they were hauling slop form the
cafeteria and no,
and it was covered.
He had found me and then he told this story.
Well,
he was sipped to an area up on the east coast.
Do you remember what that place was?
Well,
anyway,
he was taken up there and he was discharged.
So he tried to buy a motorcycle and he called my mother and found out where I
was stationed and he said,
don't tell her co Harvey where I'm at and everything.
And so he couldn't buy a motorcycle.
You didn't have enough money.
So he hitchhiked down there.
So he hitchhiked down there and took him three days to get down there.
And he got,
his uniform was a soils,
you know,
and he'd been in it for about six days and so,
and he's one of the guys that meant it had to be dressed completely.
Lynn,
that picture,
we'd tell him,
tell him that he was the only marine did ever invaded with a pressed Daenerys.
All that.
Yeah.
And fixed her the book
where it shows him from behind,
you can see the beer in his gas mask thing.
And you can also see this,
that is a uniform is pressed and starched.
Oh yeah.
And they had initially,
yeah.
I mean,
he's named Spanish to the dorm is,
uh,
is a spade,
you know,
and trenching to,
well he hid
it,
took him six dry,
uh,
six days to,
number six trips,
uh,
arrives to get down night.
I was about three or four days.
It took him to get on the east coast down to New Orleans.
Well,
it gets New Orleans and you know,
World War I knew I was on a naval base down there,
so he has no idea what to do and everything.
So he goes to a tailor shop cleaning place,
you know,
and that guy cleaned his uniform,
and,
and pressed it and everything for him because he had,
he needed to look good all the time.
So he,
he uh,
I was walking around and having no idea of what to do.
So he saw a Red Cross car parked in front of a building right there and it was a
Red Cross office day.
So he walked over and looked and it was lady,
the lady sitting at the desk.
So he has his discharge papers,
never thing in 90 left to see bag out outside.
Say,
walked in there,
he looked around,
you know,
like he was being fallen,
got the closest lane.
He said,
I've got to find a man now more on a special mission and I've got to find him.
You know,
it's a,
it's a real critical thing.
She said,
I'll help you.
She got fired up and she out that,
uh,
hours over that I ate a heights at that naval ammunition base or the,
and so she said,
I'll take you over there.
Sure.
She closes up his office or her office and in carvers holding his discharge
papers on their own,
look around,
you know,
it's,
you see,
I can put it on all night.
She'd go to town to town,
you know,
running stop lives cause this and that thing that had big red crosses on it,
and he gets him down now to the ferry boat.
That's where they had a bridge built across.
I,
so,
and she had called over to bass and they had the,
uh,
a van over to meet him,
you know,
and everything.
And,
uh,
so he pulls the car up on that,
that,
uh,
ferry boat was waiting on him and so calmer got out and he hugged that lady and
she had tears in her eyes and did her part for the country.
Oh yeah.
Secret message.
So he gets over there and this guy,
then this thing,
the old,
he looks around and he thought it shouldn't be on that admiral or something,
you know,
what needed to Pfc.
And so this,
uh,
his car had a siren on his third turn on his salary and run him down to,
the town,
uh,
a little town across,
and you got him to the base and the [inaudible] gone.
Th th that God's going to take him to the,
to the headquarters office.
He said,
oh no,
I can't stop.
I've got to go and said,
I'll get down there some way.
So He's standing there and you see this truck coming around the corner and he,
it just coming out and it had two barrels of slop from the mess hall and they,
they'd tell him,
said,
I ain't going there.
And he said,
I'm not getting up of the thing.
Million flyers around it there the thing.
And so he,
uh,
there's two guys in the trucks,
so they put him,
uh,
they take the a sea bag and put up between them and then he gets up on the hood
and sits on the cab ride die.
And when they get close to that farm where I was,
they began to honk their horn and Howard carver stomping the
hood of that truck,
hollering my name in there,
the thing.
And I was so happy to see my cry.
He came,
he came home and uh,
or,
oh really glad to see him,
you know,
it's just like losing the best friend and on the plan name and the end.
And so here I am and I'd take him over there to the sergeants.
So then charge over this on that farm that,
that owner of that farm,
when the war started donated his farm lands to be used,
bailed ammunition,
dumps,
you know,
they're worthy bar or mileage where the dig and decide my ground and,
and had the thing is about 50 those mounds along there.
And so this sergeant,
God can't fag for names,
is in charge of the farm,
you know,
because that guy orange farm farm back,
just like it was
after the war was over and they had to take care of the horses on the and the
pigs and well,
the whole eggs and uh,
take care of the house and everything.
Well,
they had the is used in the house and there were six other marines and a beside
the sergeant that was,
but it was in charge of.
So,
uh,
when carver got,
Tucker [inaudible] sergeant sergeant or working on a weekend alone,
a,
uh,
a tractor,
and I said,
hey sarge,
it's just lead dark.
He's my buddy.
Uh,
and he just got into town and they stay here.
He said,
yeah,
he can stay here.
So,
uh,
he took us in his day.
I start turning,
gave to him,
uh,
a,
a card,
you know,
to get to me out of now that I have a guy that are already left,
so here covers another name and he's own base without not even the Marine Corps
anymore.
And so,
uh,
we,
he was going to help me with the chickens.
And so,
uh,
we take with the chickens and this guy,
big old red hit a guy,
he was the guy that had the chicken job,
which he did the best job on the,
on the farm.
You had to give it up.
He,
he was mad at me,
he wouldn't even speak to me.
So here carver was owned by [inaudible] with a
okay.
Where the cards in order to let him get and all the base and uh,
it was just another marine did this then drawing the pay,
you know.
And so we stayed down there for quite a while and uh,
we decided that the chickens,
some of those chicken Jordan during the job and copper said we need to call out
the non layers.
So he called a,
uh,
yeah,
a vet veterinarian and ask him how you decided which one was layered.
And he said,
well,
put two fingers,
this pot and everything,
we got the wrong information and then we took it wrong and we killed a bunch of
those layers and it cut the production of vagues out.
We got in trouble,
they brought us,
they brought me and cause there's copper couldn't go before the man,
you know,
and they were going to send me back to the heart of the revolution and it really
mad.
And,
and this,
this sergeant where that uh,
he should run,
let them stay and I'll put them on in the hallway.
And so they put us on the hall.
That was the worst job on the deal.
So how long were you down there at the hospital and told our at the,
at the farm and total
all probably three months.
And then that was,
that was the end of your career,
you got discharged at the end of that?
Yeah,
from the hospital.
I was discharged from the hospital.
And so a free to go.
Why don't you read that out loud?
Because that introduces carbon or what they were meant to each other.
Yeah.
It's a,
a picture of you two,
and I guess this is the day you were discharged.
Yeah,
we did.
It took us out,
uh,
lieutenant,
their sergeant drovers out to the edge of town and,
uh,
I'd drink a coke or cola.
Cobre had a beer and the board lists and uh,
and that sergeant and in charge of,
he was in tears.
He aid to see us go.
And so
it says our faces are bathed in sadness.
We had just been medically discharged from the Marine Corps.
The corps,
which had been our home was now just a memory.
We loved the Marines and thought we'd always serve the flag,
but circumstances intervened.
I left us homeless.
We now faced an uncertain future.
However,
it didn't mark the end of the friendship that had been forged and nurtured by
war.
Like brothers.
We have remained close ever since.
Let's see it.
Yeah.
And there's great detail in the book,
um,
that,
that you've got to tell even more stories and,
and it's,
it's great to hear those.
And I'd definitely,
anybody,
um,
should get this book and it's available right now.
Um,
and,
uh,
I got to say there's two versions of the book and the version that you want to
order.
I will have it on our website so that people will get the right one.
It's called Hell yes.
I do it again by t Fred Harvey and it's got a blue cover and the other version
of it has a similar title.
Just get this one.
Um,
that's in blue.
What made you decide to write the book?
Well,
people learning to hear the story and I'd taken a lot of notes and so I decided
to write a book,
but it was Kinda hard for me because,
uh,
I had,
I quit high school.
The English,
well,
he did a great job because the book and you know,
reading the book,
it's a,
it's a great read.
And then you know,
you spent,
once you retired,
you said you coached football for 45 years and worked with kids and you still
were telling me you still work out every day.
Yeah.
You still get after it every day.
Uh,
weights and,
uh,
apartment I work on,
on the weights and a one will run the machines where you pump paddle and,
and I stay in shape and eat the right kind of food
and uh,
I want her to die happy.
So what I'm saying,
name good to health and that's awesome.
You know,
I wanted to,
I want to close out,
um,
by reading one,
one last little piece of the book and um,
yeah,
well I'll just do it.
Okay.
And,
and this is,
um,
this is you.
We went to visit,
uh,
Eol Jima.
You went back to the island in the early eighties,
and this is something that you wrote as you were leaving the island after you
went and visited the place where you had fought and where you lost so many
friends.
And the book says for each and every wave that has crashed upon these shores
since those days so long ago,
the mother has shed a tear for a son who fought and died here.
Many of those mothers at this time have gone to be with their sons.
Okay.
Here,
pride took over.
You screamed loudly and ran straight ahead.
Yeah,
it's notoriety was written in blood and courage.
Absent are the sounds of battle that emphasized the human voice in all its
emotions against a backdrop of roaring cannons and small arms fire.
The engines of war are silent now
you owe Gima today offers an innocuous view
in stark contrast to what took place here in the winter of 1945
but hurtful and injurious qualities that it supported those days so long ago.
No longer are in evidence.
Okay?
Yes,
the engines of war are silent here,
but man has cranked them up many times since in other lands.
You whoa today still offers a landscape that features a rugged coarseness.
Everything that took place on this spot emphasize strength,
power,
and courage
time and it's help mates.
Wind and rain have erased the scars of war on the landscape,
but still it presents a paradox with a rugged beauty about it.
Time on the contrary has not healed.
The scars left on the hearts and bodies of those who fought here.
There's nothing so brutal as when men point their brutality toward each other.
Yeah.
My plane is rising to take me back to Japan.
I looked down on he,
whoa.
As a new day is having its beginning,
loneliness and sadness have crept a board.
My heart holds many unsaid words as I can't put into words,
the fragments of my thoughts and feelings.
Okay.
Thoughts and feelings that I can't ignore.
A pain of unreasoning desolation.
Yeah.
I'm engulfed by a gray veil of sadness.
I leave with mixed emotions.
I'm glad that I came while I regretting the return.
Yeah.
Though great distances separate me from this island.
The thought of it,
yeah.
Is always just a heartbeat away.
I'm determined not to ever forget the man I marched among.
Okay.
All my tears will not ever wash away.
The memories.
Now in the twilight of my years,
all I've got on my yesterdays and a whole arsenal of memories
and hell yes,
I do it again.
Once a marine,
always a marine.
That wraps up the books or
I don't know if you have any thing else you want to say before we wrap this up.
Uh,
thank you.
Just said it far,
made that
Aye
loved the Marines
and uh,
don't know it.
Sometime and
future.
Oh,
John,
those moraines march through eternity with each other.
It'd be a home comment.
Thank you.
Thank you sir.
And obviously thanks for coming on.
More important thanks for your service and your sacrifice for our great nation.
Well it was an honor to serve you in this great country of ours and God bless
the soul.
Thank you sir.
Thanks for coming on.
My pleasure.
And Mr t Fred Harvey has left the building and that was pretty,
pretty incredible and thanks to everyone of you listeners for giving us the
opportunity to speak to these incredible heroes and share their stories.
And none of this would be possible without your support.
So if you do want to support this podcast and actually at the same time you can
support yourself.
Of course.
That's kind of the way we've set things up.
Now,
Echo,
perhaps you could show us the way to properly support.
Sure,
of course.
Be Happy to.
All right.
First way is origin main.com game.
So origin.
That's the company,
our company,
Pete Robert's company in Maine,
so it's called the origin main.com.
Anyway,
this is where,
okay.
At first the first thing you want to do to support yourself.
Very important by the way,
joint supplements,
Krill oil.
That's to me in everyday stuff.
Actually both,
all of these are most of these everyday supplements.
I think there's some that might not necessarily be classified as an everyday
supplements.
Yeah,
like the monk named not be everyday.
Well for Sir.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That that's like maybe could,
maybe could.
Yeah,
I guess I would say the one that I would say discipline.
You don't need that every day.
Straight up.
Krill and joint.
Yeah.
Joint Warfarin.
Krill oil.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's daily.
So Chris,
Super Krill oil to be,
not to split hairs,
but Jocko Super Krill oil is a Krill oil supplement and when people ask me still
now like,
hey,
there's fish oil is krill oil?
What's better?
Krill oil is better.
Not just because I like it better,
factually better.
This is why has more antioxidants,
better absorption,
better meaning like numbers wise chat and I can go into why you want me to do,
I will.
I'm not really sure,
but I make it.
Three is the Omega threes get attached to your phospholipids as opposed to do
inquiry in fish oil.
Don't make it three skid attached to the triglycerides,
so,
oh,
very.
Yeah.
That method of delivery delivers a higher percentage of Omega threes.
Boom into your situation,
decides to stop the thing you had limited science.
I still don't understand how it works if you know that as a fact,
unless I'm lying,
which I'm not.
You know how it works as a fact.
You see what I'm saying?
There's a difference between me saying,
I tell you what,
I know.
You feel better.
All right.
See,
that's a very unscientific.
You'd be like,
okay,
I feel better.
Wait a second.
Honestly,
if I came to you with a book and explain this to you,
technically,
what would,
what would have more weight?
Me being like,
Hey,
here's how this works with the phosphorous genic materials moving through your
membranes.
Or if I was like,
Bro,
you got to try this cause it,
it works.
Yeah.
Which one would carry more weight with me?
You well know with me,
I think the book,
Oh Trump's I because the reason that you're making the action of really good
point in my opinion,
that one,
you know the whole,
it's like a social proof,
right?
Social proof.
That's it.
That's like a real thing.
But you started oil because I told you.
Cause you,
yeah.
Despite everything that the [inaudible] speaking of not telling a lie,
I'm saying Nah.
Well you know what?
You're absolutely right.
It actually,
I'll do you one better.
Actually.
You'll do your cell phone better.
You told me to take Krill oil.
I took real.
My father in law has been taking me,
telling me to take krill oil for a decade.
Literally one decade.
No krill oil.
Does he listen to the podcast?
I hope not.
I don't.
I'm not to cause otherwise you're in trouble,
but highly disappointed nonetheless.
I'll tell you what it does.
It keeps your joints healthy.
Healthy joints are happy.
Julian's as far as joints being happy because that's near the little jingle
saying it's true.
It's true.
Anyway,
it's,
yeah.
This is one of those things where it's like,
it's,
it's like a,
it's a marked.
When I said it's not the kind of like,
Hey,
I just feel better.
It's,
it's not that that's really ambiguous in my opinion.
When you're like,
Hey,
I just feel better,
you know,
I just feel bad.
You're like,
all right bro.
You don't like,
there's a lot things that can make you feel better.
Like you get a good TV show on it.
That'll make you feel better.
Tech technically no.
Technically no.
Technically for most people that are not,
you bet.
No problem.
Then the last,
you see one of these,
see what I'm saying?
When you watch a good,
let's say a good TV show.
Okay.
You Watch Hawaii five o yes.
You're saying you,
if I have,
I mean,
I'm not gonna speak for you.
If I watch a TV program the whole time I'm watching a good TV program,
there's something nagging in the back of my mind that's saying like,
you could be doing something else.
You could be improving yourself.
Yeah,
you're right.
You could be making progress somewhere.
You could be prepping for a pot.
You'd be doing another workout.
He'd be swinging a kettle bell.
I'm not sitting there going,
oh,
Michelle,
so awesome.
I feel so good about it.
Am I right or wrong?
But you are right for yourself.
I can see how you could think that.
There's times where you're watching the TV and you're pumped up,
like saying you're okay.
Yeah,
that's cool.
If it was one of the things,
well,
here's the thing though.
You Still Watch that TV program.
It wasn't on this week,
this past week,
because that's the season finale was last week,
so you know we're off.
I don't know if you sell wash after the incident,
the incident.
Anyway,
my point is if you,
someone says,
it makes me feel better or better in the way they say it is a real general way.
It's less compelling than them saying like me in my situation,
I'm like,
Hey,
when I woke up freaking,
I did like practice perfect form in getting up out of my bed for my back,
not to bother me.
Super Bad to the point of it,
I actually admitting that it's painful sometimes.
Actually it's not painful.
It's just like,
you know,
he just got to do it.
Yeah,
and my daughter would jump on the back.
All this stuff.
Your backyard
sometimes.
Yeah.
Anyway,
take Krill oil,
boom.
Six days a week later,
boom and dog jumping on my back.
No problem.
I fly out of bed like I just warmed up.
Same deal.
See,
here's the thing,
I didn't look as much into the scientific part of joint.
Poor.
Fair.
Speaking of science,
why don't you explain your arm injury before?
Yeah.
Joint Warfare Current.
Yeah,
so this is pretty compelling.
Very compelling in my opinion too.
So,
so same deal.
This is an anecdotal situation where,
okay,
all right.
Some of us may know I tore my bicep tendon off the bone again,
again,
the other side.
Now,
hey man says that bicep life,
you know,
it happens anyway.
So yeah,
this was what,
three weeks ago?
Slavery.
Proud.
The way I made a joke.
I thought I was proud of the joke,
but the way you explained to me that because your biceps are so massive,
it puts extra tension on the tendons and that's why they got torn.
Even though you're explaining it like it's your hard done by.
But the reality is you kind of got a big smile on your face.
All proud of the guns anyway.
No,
I'm proud of the joke.
Okay.
Anyway,
is that real though?
Oh,
I think here's a more accurate way of putting it.
So yeah.
So okay.
When you train biceps,
right?
Typically,
typically then some people did,
people turn messed up there,
but typically you don't go all the way down to straight like no elbow mobility
and then all the way up with a super heavyweight,
you just can't do that heavy weight unless you train that way the whole time.
So the corners and training in a way,
you know you can,
you can tell her that and,
and I dig it.
Yeah.
So when it comes to is there cheating
is total 90 sweat bodybuilding.
I was bro,
that's real though than that.
So when you develop strength in your biceps with size and all that stuff,
when you do develop the strength,
the strength exists mainly on a certain part of the curve of the range of
motion.
Right.
So,
but that strength is still there big time your biceps muscle or super strong.
But when you extend it to this flight you still kind of have that strength in
the muscle.
But down there it's,
I don't know,
it's like the stability of the structure just isn't as much.
And I know this is me.
Was your arm fully extended?
Both.
Both Times.
Both Times fully extended and me just,
just a little flex,
flex,
flex in Rd.
I just going to hard,
you know,
at the time one was in a tournament,
which obviously makes sense cause you're,
yeah,
if you're at an after it.
And the other time I was just got too excited training with the training partner
I haven't trained with for long term escalation.
Yeah,
yeah.
Little fire up,
we'll say escalation.
Yeah.
But anyway,
nonetheless tore off the bones.
Bad deal.
It's not one of those deals where it's like,
oh,
I pulled my muscle or whatever this is.
So you gotta go in and they cut it open.
Whenever they stretch it back down,
they staple it or whatever.
Back to the Mamon actually they drill in your bone.
He told me that this is,
they drill in your bone,
make little holes and they staple it inside the hole.
They didn't,
they staple it up,
stitch you up.
So I got that less than a week ago,
by the way.
Less than a week,
literally.
And so I'm like,
all right,
I gotta,
you know,
I'm out of the game for a little bit.
I got to get back in as quick as I can.
I upped my dosage of during warfare.
Krill oil stayed the same.
Joint Warfare,
uh,
doubled.
Actually didn't double it.
Almost double.
I was taking two a day.
Now I'd take three and in the morning and then two at night.
Right.
It's almost double.
So I do have a basis of comparison cause like you said,
like we know I had the exact same injury,
exact same injury on the other side,
same surgery,
same everything nine years ago.
By the way,
I wasn't like I'm older now so that's something too.
So this recovery like given right now it's like way quicker.
Like this morning while I'm putting it on,
I'm putting on pants or pants.
By the way,
I literally forgot I had the injury just for a sec.
You know,
you're just like doing it or whatever.
And we're not even a week out.
Not even a week yet.
Cause you were laid up for a while for the other nine years ago when you were
young buck.
Yep.
Same exact injury.
Boom.
Yeah.
And nothing,
nothing.
Nothing is good for that is more compelling than you explaining the science
behind it.
I am not saying I don't believe the science.
I'm saying I'm talking to you right now and I've seen this with my own eyes.
So that's like,
to me it makes more sense.
It doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
This is,
yeah,
it's,
to me,
I'm more surprised.
Like my wife gets mad at me.
It's like,
you're injured,
you're going to this and that.
Cause I'm just like,
cruising tip off the slang or whatever.
Who's around lifting weights?
Not with this arm eating nuts.
Actually,
I'm kind of doing push up,
push up on it.
Um,
but yeah,
it's like,
like there's no paint,
nothing,
no inflammation.
Well,
very little inflammation nonetheless.
Um,
you,
I think the,
like,
what do you call it?
The scientific kind of information versus the pier,
um,
the approval,
you know,
what do you call,
period.
It's called something.
I said it earlier.
Then the less like if I tell you like,
oh,
this works for me.
And like legitimately,
um,
if you're a of the whole deal,
like a very like,
I don't know if this works,
then the scientific lake stuff for some reason,
if there's some reason for me to be telling you like to do something like go to
a psychic,
then in a terrible,
yeah.
Yeah.
And then I'll be like,
no bro,
you're dumb for doing that.
And then you see some scientific literature they need have more compelling if it
song.
No,
I read the scientific literature and obviously as we were putting it all
together,
it was like,
all right,
let's get the right stuff in there,
which is stuff that I had used from other supplements in the past.
But combine it all into one.
There you go.
Boom.
Alright.
Jocko supplements all still speaking of which discipline,
this is the one you mentioned that you don't take every day.
See it.
Who does take it every day?
Dave bird,
Dave,
which is kind of all about it,
which is kind of something because is one of those smart guys like Dave,
he's kind of one of these guys who's like you said,
achiever,
that guy,
he met his brother by the way.
So if he's doing it every day,
there could be something to do that.
That's what I think is another one of those.
He,
the way he talked to me about it,
he got all crazy like big smile and it was like I got it on it.
I take it at this time at night,
that way I could up and down and it gets me off.
I was like,
Dang Dave Dang.
Even though micro dose of caffeine.
Yeah,
no microdose before you go to bed.
Well he's probably used to the caffeine.
That's why I said,
well no,
he does it.
He takes it far enough ahead of when his family goes to bed.
He's like taking it and then he gets a couple hours worth of good solid output.
Yeah.
And then when he goes to,
now here's a weird thing about caffeine.
Just as a side note,
I've drank a coffee before and went to sleep.
It's almost like the coffee put me to sleep.
I'm not like that.
No,
because you don't drink caffeine.
I don't drink a lot of caffeine.
Breath.
You drank like a big cog light blue one.
I drink bro.
Leave me like during the muster cause we're getting limited sleep during the
muster.
Even limited for my standards.
I take caffeine.
I mean I take,
I take this right here,
I take this right here.
I think Jocko white tea and I take the discipline but you just keep drinking in
the hydro and a lot of it.
Yeah cause you know busy our coffee that you figure what 15 per serving
milligrams and then so like one of those things I was drinking,
no,
not today but the other day is 300 milligrams of caffeine.
That's just done so that if you sipped on that like over a two,
three hour period and just drink the whole thing.
Ultimately you will be no,
there's times where I've drank like tons of red bull and just been like,
which is why I tried to taper off the heavy caffeine,
taper off the heavy caffeine.
That's why I don't make beverages that have 900 milligrams caffeine because it
does.
It doesn't and you don't need that.
You don't want that.
You started getting,
it starts,
it starts having other effects.
You start getting to like you talk too much.
Right.
You talked too much.
Actually speaking of talking too much,
I just met someone that came to roll and they were like,
oh yeah,
you know,
it's really good to meet you because I listen to podcasts.
He's like,
cool.
And then we rolled in,
we talked a little bit and he's like,
you're just like on the podcast.
And I said,
well,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean it's just we're hitting record as we discuss things.
And then I said probably the biggest difference between me on the podcast and me
and real life is that in real life,
I don't,
in the podcast I talk the whole time.
And in real life I actually don't talk very much.
I talk a lot less,
I should say.
Yeah.
Especially with people.
I don't know what people,
I don't know.
I'm not very conversational when I know someone of them.
Cool.
Talk.
But so if you put 200 milligrams of caffeine rather than 15 he'd be talking to a
lot your whole thing.
Well,
it would be making me act out of character.
It'd be,
it'd be influencing me in a negative way.
In a negative way,
I believe.
Yeah.
But if you can just get in the zone.
It sharpens the mind.
I mean,
caffeine is proven,
proven to sharpen you up.
So anyways,
to each his own,
you know,
I think most people who like caffeine,
like coffee and stuff,
like they liked that and that's what,
that's one thing.
If you,
if you know you might need more discipline,
you might need more caffeine.
They get feel it if you're not,
if you're used to it,
if you have a,
what's that tolerance,
low tolerances or if high telling him through,
but yeah,
and deal with face it.
Discipline Jocko white tea.
That's not why you drinking.
You don't drink it.
That's not why.
That's you'll include the caffeine,
the caffeine,
definitely.
It's a little microbus get you,
get you rocking and rolling.
But yeah,
that's good.
Discipline.
Cognitive enhancement.
That's what you're going to get for free.
You do some stuff,
stuff that needs braid output.
That's when you take it.
That's what I take it.
That's what good.
That's when good deal Dave takes it and that's when Jocko takes it all.
So milk,
this is
protein powder,
but to call it protein powders kind of discern a disservice for sure.
Cause it's just go with mold.
Here's the thing though,
I don't,
we don't want someone I person,
I know I'll speak for myself.
I don't want someone to hear,
hey mark,
Hey,
what is that?
Okay.
Tastes good.
All this stuff.
But like,
you know,
there's less stuff that tastes good.
You will get good protein from milk.
Yes.
Your will to do it.
All that.
And there's probiotics.
Oh no kidding.
See it and see what's good.
What doesn't.
Probiotics.
Okay.
Maybe for you it's not like this.
When I hear probiotics,
I always think like,
oh,
that's something that,
um,
you know,
someone's like,
oh,
you gotta take your probiotics.
Right.
It's not something,
you know,
for me it's like,
oh,
I'm gonna drink protein.
Good probiotic says I'm not worried about that.
But,
so I never,
I've taken them a couple times before,
but there's probiotics in it.
And so now I realize like,
I feel good,
like my gut feels good.
So maybe there's something to that probiotic activity.
When you say maybe I'm not like that.
You're correct.
And I'm not like that.
Probiotics are good antibiotic.
Well antibiotics are good,
but,
and
so probiotics are like their probiotic
Welson
basically like your Gut biome,
right?
It promotes healthy,
healthy bacteria,
all this stuff.
And you're thinking proud.
It's a huge deal actually.
I know,
I know.
And now,
now I'm starting to realize that I started to realize I've been rolling for 46
years.
It's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like if I have like a metaphor right now,
if I have the,
you're the key to life,
right?
The whole,
the answer to life,
right?
What is the meaning of life and have it,
I have been a man.
I'm going to,
I'm about to tell you right?
But you have your plugs in so you can't hear me.
I still told you.
But you can't get in your brain because you have your foot.
Well,
you put that probiotics,
boom takes earplugs out.
Boom.
You got it in your brain.
Same thing.
The same exact thing.
Except I own two or an advertisement.
I think that's just incredible.
Maybe I will.
It's called milk.
And it is mint chocolate,
peanut butter,
peanut,
chocolates,
comments,
and then it's just going to do,
I think we're good on chocolate.
Just straight chocolate because you were good.
Like I've got the sample and I had it this weekend and and yes it is g o double
d.
Good.
Well I think the chocolate is kind of the staple,
right?
Is it is and that's why it seems a little while because it's hard to nail.
It
tastes like chocolate and not die and chocolate or something like
it.
Diet,
anything.
Cool.
Well nonetheless be that look up for that and that is if you're taking protein
powder and they're like,
hey,
I want some good quality protein powder.
Forget about the term protein powder because that gives you the idea that this
is going to taste like crap and this is,
this is the miracle.
It tastes delicious and it tastes delicious and it's got no sugar in it.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Very cool.
Awesome.
Whatever it is.
I have a gram,
it's got,
I might have like a gram,
we'll put it this way.
It's not full with sugar.
Like the old school mega math 5 million.
Oh yeah.
In the big dog knockoff bag.
Remember that?
Oh yeah,
that was good.
That tastes it kinda good with monk fruit.
Yeah,
that's what that,
so if you're wondering like well how does it taste?
Not like the artificial sweeteners that people serve up,
which tastes nasty.
Like no matter what it tastes like crap.
It's monkfruit creamy.
I mean that's a weird question but like monk fruit because it doesn't taste
like,
you know how you use like a,
um,
I guess,
you know,
like a sweetener.
It has a fruity sweet and thing like the chocolate mint.
I don't know what it looks like,
its raw form,
but I know that it tastes freaking delicious.
I'm gonna look into that one and I will report back.
Speaking of reporting back,
if in fact you want to look at it this way,
I am reporting back to the three people this week.
They asked me what gee,
should I get when I started Jujitsu.
So I know to most of us,
this is obvious right now,
but I will answer this question in anyway.
It is an origin,
Geeky and rash guard.
If you're doing it,
don't keep by the way,
but you get an origin get,
you'd get the origin g for many reasons.
Not only because it's the best seat,
but because it's made in America as well and there's plenty options on there.
So me saying get an orange gene.
It's not just one origin.
Gee,
I guess technically in a way you just get if it's an orgy as good and,
but you have many different options within the brand of origin.
Jeez.
So go there.
Like I said,
origin main.com that's where you get everything made in America.
Made in America from the dirt to the shirt.
Meaning,
cause if you don't really know what that means,
it might not make as much sense.
But when you do know what I mean to,
we'll make sense.
This is what it means.
The cotton is grown from America or in America from the dirt.
Get it.
No.
Then on the shirt at the end,
we're technically,
it's a g or whatever,
whatever you get,
boom.
Anyway.
Made America everything.
Origin main.com.
Also
there's an immersion camp.
Jujitsu immersion camp filling up by the way.
Yeah.
Showing up quick.
He'll get on that.
Well the space is big,
so which is good.
The,
yeah.
Yeah.
The jujitsu at them at the muster was how big.
That was.
Good man.
And he was still not big enough,
I think.
Yeah.
We're ready to order more match,
but yeah,
it was gonna be awesome.
Yeah.
I sort of have an announcement to make on that too.
All right.
You know,
he's coming up to that camp.
They don't meet uh,
a guy by the name of Dean lister.
Yay.
Okay.
Good.
The knowledge.
Exactly.
Just to just straight knowledge and if you come up,
you get a chance to learn from dean lister and yeah.
That's as good as it's gonna get.
Yeah.
He was one of those guys,
like kind of those wizard types.
Yeah.
Like I remember it and grind it out.
Not even a kind of like thing.
So straight up he's got,
he's got a,
um,
uh,
a gift,
like a legit gift that people do not have you ever,
and I'm not even asking who do you have you ever,
cause I know you have probably many times what you need,
you're asked dean of question about like this problem that you're having and
you're having it because the guy who's doing it to you this too is just super
good,
but you're having this problem and you're kind of halfway thinking,
actually more than halfway thinking this is not really an answerable question,
but whatever the more info I have in the ass for him.
And then he solves your problem and you're like,
oh,
have you been thinking about this the whole time?
You know,
all this Jujitsu stuff or whatever while all of us have been living life kind of
thing.
That's what it seems like.
He taught something the other day and it's from,
Oh,
you know,
I used a crucifix a lot.
Sure.
So he taught something from the crucifix that I'd never saw before.
Never thought of.
And he did it like it was just like,
you know,
like taking a breath.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
when you get this,
you do this.
And I'm like,
are you serious?
I've been training with you for 20,
um,
23 years and you never maybe gave me a heads up on that.
And Yeah.
And the reason is,
the reason is there's so much in his brain,
there's so much that discern his brain.
He can't even figure out what to tell you unless you come to him with a problem.
That's why it's great that when you,
if you're coming to the immersion camp,
come with problems for dean.
Come with,
come with questions for dean cause that's what you want.
And then you can draw the answers out that you need from him.
Cause there's too much.
You can't download everything from his brain.
You can't,
it's not like he's going to teach you like you learned this one thing.
No,
you,
you're going to have to bring questions to him that then he'll solve problems
for you.
That's what I,
real quick,
did you get to camp uh,
immersion camp?
Yes.
26 September through May 2nd did you say that already?
Oh,
sorry.
I guess I said it wrong.
End of August.
Oh good.
You know I remember that because that is my son's birthday.
August one August 26 through September 2nd two sessions.
Or you can say for the whole set of the whole time.
The whole deal.
Yeah,
man.
Good deal.
Good.
Register at a register at origin.
May Not call late.
He's going Leif Babin.
Dave Berg.
Good deal,
Dave.
Yep.
I'm going Jj.
Easy.
I think it's going.
How's this dean?
When I got my surgery last week,
I'm going in for my surgery.
Dean is,
they're just coming out of his surgery,
so how is he going to be as far as,
he won't be able to go roll hard,
but yesterday I trained yesterday just a little in house,
little core group of guys.
We came and trained and dean came and coached and he was showing moves.
Yeah.
So this is,
yeah,
he was putting crash.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll be there kind of on the,
on the you'll be on the,
yeah,
on the fence.
They're like,
I rolled with Pete,
um,
like,
you know where before I got my surgery,
but my bicep was Dan and I just put my hand like this.
I couldn't,
can eat,
just basically can't pull,
I can't name it.
This is my injury.
I said I can't pull,
you just have to be careful.
Yeah.
So I could do a lot of that kind of rolling,
but I got it.
It's,
it's hard.
I can't roll probably with like,
you know,
like a level 12 and less experience or something like that I'll be with,
you can't roll with me.
I'll roll with Pete.
That's all.
I basically just trust Pete.
That's it.
Pretty one.
But yeah,
go to that.
That'd be fun.
Don't worry.
What level did you see your ad?
Even if you're at literally level zero?
We had level level zero people came last year,
like a burst.
Just a group of them too,
for sure.
It's good for me to get it.
Say I'll come and get it all.
So for fitness gear,
the best fitness gear,
some of the best fitness gear,
all the food is gear.
I have pretty much on it.com/chocolate that's where he get it.
Also.
I got audit socks by the way.
Freaking awesome.
Got One right now.
Um,
yeah,
get the,
get the primal belt of the kettle bells.
See what I'm saying?
And when you're looking for the information before you start the kettle bells
this,
these can be dangerous Rao swinging around big cannon balls.
Yeah,
sure.
Can have a mishap.
Yeah,
look at that big time
and they got some good information on technique and all that stuff.
It's good.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
All right.com/jocko also when you get the books that Jocko reviews on this
podcast,
I got them organized on the website.
Jocko.
Podcast dot books from the episode is a little tab on the top.
Click on there,
boom.
I got them all organized by episode a,
click through their ticket,
Amazon and you know,
do your shopping and get the book,
get whatever else,
keep shopping,
whatever or not,
whatever you like.
The lessons,
good way to support.
If you do also subscribe to the podcast,
if you haven't already on stitcher and iTunes and Google play and wherever you
or where have you listened to the,
uh,
to the podcast because there's a lot of podcasts apps out there and I get it.
It's good.
It's good thing.
Vast marketplace of podcast apps get in there.
Nonetheless,
subscribe when you do,
and that's a good way to support also on youtube video version of this podcast
if you're interested in that video version.
Uh,
also we got as excerpts on there,
good reason to subscribe in my opinion.
So when I put on an expert,
maybe that's the one that really you're waiting for rather than sifting through
all the episodes and then 15 through the episode,
which is three,
four hours long sometimes,
and then,
oh,
there it is.
And then listening to it kind of thing.
You know,
I don't know how practical that is sometimes.
So boom,
I try to put all the excerpts,
all the points,
all the significant points.
And there's a lot,
by the way,
that Jocko makes,
had to put them in excerpts on the youtube channel.
Maybe that's the one you were looking for.
It's a good witness,
a good reason to subscribe in my opinion.
So yeah,
do that.
Good way to support it as well.
Also,
chocolate is a store.
It's called Jocko Star,
so let me ask you this,
not you,
Jocko.
That's the people.
Have you ever looked at Jocko shirt and been like,
you know what?
I wish I had that shirt or have you ever looked at a shirt that I wear that says
discipline equals freedom.
If you ever looked at that and said,
Dang,
I want that shirt.
Guess what?
This place you can get,
it's called Jocko store.com that's where you can get it.
Discipline equals freedom.
Get after it shirt.
The actual shirt that Jack was wearing right now,
literally the one that Jack was wearing right now,
you can get that shirt represent big time.
Good way to support and support yourself.
There's also rash guards and stuff on their patches.
Hoodies,
hats,
new hats.
By the way,
trucker hat,
trucker hats had left truck.
Yeah,
the flex it.
I thought you'd like to flex it is,
I don't like flex.
It actually,
but I know that's,
that's probably the preferred hat in the population of the of the world is the
flex fit.
Yeah.
I think select trucker hats.
Old School Burke.
Have you ever worn a flex fit hat?
Yes.
I'll straight up.
You don't like that one?
You don't like the convenience of this?
The flex fit,
I guess if you have the snap back,
you just put it on one side and not with your head gets bigger.
My head does not get bigger or smaller on a day.
Really?
Cause after we roll sometimes I feel like your head's kind of bigger.
No,
I think that just made,
it might be the way you feel.
Mine's just,
I get it.
None the less.
Both types of hats on their women's stuff on there as well.
I'm putting tank tops on there,
so look,
be on the lookout for that.
Like for for dudes tank tops.
There's,
yeah,
there's already women's tank tops on there,
so we're going to get dudes going.
Going to school.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly right.
Boom.
Summer,
summertime.
Yeah,
right.
Boom.
Shot the gun,
Sun's out.
Guns out.
Beans out.
Beanies that are in for just in time for summer.
All good.
Um,
but you know,
some places like Alaska summertime's called to,
so boom,
get the beanie.
Also psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
it's an album jockos album on iTunes with tracks,
Jocko tracks in his what is not Jocko singing.
It's chocolate talking to you.
Every track has chocolate talking to you.
And what he's telling you,
his reasons why you shouldn't give in to the weakness that you will be giving
into sometimes if you don't have this,
you will be giving into this weakness on your path,
on your campaign against weakness,
on the path,
on the war path.
We're all on the path by the way,
are we not?
Oh,
so yeah.
Well here's the thing.
I think you're kind of a leader on this path.
I kind of evaluated this.
Okay.
No and,
and I'm,
I was into working out before I get it,
you know,
but it's the kind of where like if I didn't feel like working out,
it's like I just kind of won't work out.
I'll do it tomorrow cause I will.
And I would usually,
you know,
kind of thing.
But when you kind of quantify it as this path and when,
when when the the term campaign against weakness,
the weakness kind of got introduced to,
that's a really good thing too because generally speaking,
that's really what jams you up in,
in my opinion,
in my experience where yeah,
if I don't feel like doing it right,
I don't feel like doing it.
That's a weakness,
right?
If I say,
oh number do cause I don't feel like it,
then you go through life not feeling like doing stuff and not doing it and most
of the time we don't feel like it.
Especially as you get older,
especially as you take on other responsibilities.
But if you make it a point to understand that I'm gunna consciously not feel
like doing something,
understanding that it needs to be done,
then kind of fight that kind of weakness there.
That's a bath I'm talking about and this will help you with that.
Yeah.
Oh sorry.
Back to the psychological worker.
I think you wrapped it up nicely
to me.
It's more to understand that because the more that in my opinion or in my
experience,
the more I understood that the more like kind of affective,
you know you are in staying on this path.
So anyway,
when you reach like a little small point of weakness,
you listen to this album specific track that is designated for that weakness,
hundred percent hundred percent you will not give in to that weakness.
That's good.
Psychological warfare.
We need to make a second album.
People need to ask what they want to hear,
what moments of weakness and need to be overcome.
Yeah.
I know had some for like smoking.
Some for a drinking.
Drinking would be good on check.
Yeah,
it is.
The way it was born was because of a weakness that I specifically specifically
had like something that it kind of like got to me late,
you know like later on,
like during the,
at the time I'm like,
Hey,
whatever.
Or why should I put this much pressure on my shell itself is that,
you know,
is that healthy?
You ever do that?
None of you,
I know you don't do that.
Come on,
let's face it.
It's kind of like one of those things where it's like it's a justification,
but it's like,
ah,
like hey,
you shouldn't put so much pressure on yourself,
you know,
don't add this stress.
Hey,
life is stressful.
Don't add more stress like this.
You don't want to,
when it's like,
it's just an excuse and my stress,
it's true sound effect thing.
Are you ready?
So Jocko white tea,
obviously for a long time we've had tea bags that you can get a,
what's that called?
Dry Tea is what it's called.
Jocko.
White tea available on Amazon.
Real tasty
and good for you.
And we just got it made and put into cans.
So here we go.
Sound effects.
Are you ready?
Here we go.
This is a Jocko white tea opening.
Oh,
there you go.
So now you can get Jocko white.
Tina can,
it is
delicious and it's good for you.
And you know,
even if even if you don't like the taste,
even if you don't play like that,
it's good for you.
You will like the fact that after you drank one can,
you'll be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds minimum minimum.
That's the minimum and it's been proven scientifically backwards and forwards.
Double Blind,
placebo,
whatever you want to call it.
Yeah,
John,
it's,
it's available only Amazon.
Eventually we'll get it everywhere.
That's the goal.
But right now it's available on Amazon because that's the quickest way to get it
out to everyone.
So there you go.
Get it.
Victory and a can organic.
Did I tell you that?
Certified organic certified organic in the beginning and just because I'm
impressed.
No Gmos,
no,
no reason to go and drink a drink that's going to have filled with a bunch of
stuff that you don't want your body agree.
Just drink Jocko white tea.
All right,
books.
We've got the way the warrior kids series and I got um,
here's just a little note.
A kid,
a guy wrote my eight year old who read your Breck way of the warrior care to in
January of 2018.
Since then he's gone.
Beast mode runs 1.3 kilometers most mornings before school and 2.6 kilometers on
the weekends.
He trains,
plays and enjoys life.
Since reading your book,
his room was immaculately tidy.
Your book switched something in him.
He is self motivated and strives to achieve.
We talk about 1% in life and doing the small things well in school and sports.
Thanks for your service and the book.
So there you go.
No big deal,
right?
Can you imagine that?
That's freaking awesome.
I love this room is immaculate.
He's on the path.
You know the path.
So pick up way the warrior kid and Mark's mission.
Get your kid on the path.
If you want to support a war,
your kid named Aiden that's making things happen.
Go to Irish ranch.com
and get some of the soap that he makes on his farm from goat milk.
He makes Jocko soap so you can stay clean.
Don't forget about the discipline equals freedom field manual.
Of course.
Um,
this was awesome.
I was at the muster and we're doing PT.
It's for whenever,
four 35 in the morning or something.
And this woman comes up to me and she's a little older and she just looks at me
and she's like,
can I tell you something though?
That look was on her face.
And so I gave her the nod of like,
go ahead and tell me.
And she's like,
it was November 7th,
2017 and I was at Sam's Club and I saw this book as Black Book and I never saw a
book like that and I picked it up and looked at it and said this,
I've never seen anything like this.
She bought it and since that time that she's lost 23 pounds and she said she's
got her life back.
Boom.
That's awesome.
So you know who you are out there,
so thank you for letting me know that.
That was a very cool story to hear and I appreciate that feedback.
That's the discipline equals freedom field manual thoughts and actions both
inside.
If you want the audio version of that,
which people still ask me every single day,
you can't get it on audible.
It's not on audible.
It's on Amazon music,
iTunes,
Google play,
and other MP3 platforms as an album with tracks.
Also for leadership.
Of course,
there's the first book,
extreme ownership,
the leadership book for the battlefield,
business and life,
and actually somebody else,
the muster said,
hey,
you never talk about the audible version of extreme ownership because that is
available on audible,
and guess who reads it?
Leif Babin and me and the,
and this guy was saying,
you should,
everyone should be listened to that.
It's,
it's,
it's better to listen to it then to read it,
which that depends on who you are,
but for this individual,
he was like,
you need to tell people about that.
That's awesome that you guys and anyone else's on that audio book sound effects.
We put sound effects in their machine gun,
fire explosions,
things like that.
You know why?
Because immersion immersion,
so yeah,
so you can get that.
I'll also
coming out September 25th we have the follow on book two extreme ownership.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It's available for preorder wherever you want to preorder Amazon,
Barnes,
noble,
local bookstore.
It's going to be out September 25th
if you want one of the first edition copies,
which you do.
If you want to be a book,
a book person like me,
you want to get that first edition because that's cool and if you don't order it
then you won't get it in time because the publisher won't make enough because
they have no idea.
They don't understand how many people are out there waiting for this book.
So if you it order it,
that'd be cool.
If you want to work with us in person,
call Ashkelon Front,
it's me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
our website is echelon front.com and we solve problems through leadership.
That's it.
Of course,
the monster leadership seminar
Oh five oh five was in Washington DC.
It was awesome.
And it sold out.
Yes.
And there's only one more master in 2018 it's mustard zero zero six in San
Francisco,
California,
October 17th and 18th register@extremeownership.com if you want to come,
it will sell out and that's all there is to it.
And also for current law enforcement,
military firefighters,
paramedics and other first responders.
Rollcall zero zero one September 21st in Dallas,
Texas,
one day leadership training seminar focused on people in uniform.
You can register for that.
Also add extreme ownership.com and until the monster or the roll call or the
immersion camp in Maine.
If you want to communicate with us,
you know that you can find us on the interwebs.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and to the men of the greatest generation like
Mr t Fred Harvey.
Thank you for your service and to the rest of the men and women out there
continuing to hold the line thanks to you and to your families for what you do
every day and what they do to support you.
Of course,
thanks to all the force,
first responders,
police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and those who stand the watch 24 seven to keep us safe and to the
rest of you.
Okay.
Life can be hard and life can be challenging and life can contain a fair amount
of suffering,
but you know what?
It's the one life you've got.
So go and live a life that in the end allows you to look back and say,
hell yes,
I do it all again.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.